Ogu, wie machst du das eigentlich? Hast du einen Bot? Wie kriegst du das immer so schnell
mit? Du bist immer, oder vielleicht lässt du ja einen Bot für dich posten, keine Ahnung,
weil du bist immer so schnell da. Du bist meistens innerhalb der ersten 30 Sekunden,
nachdem ich auf Start gedrückt habe da und das ist verdächtig. So schnell ist sonst
eigentlich niemand da. Du bist selbst da. Mittlerweile weiß man das ja auch nicht.
Es gibt ja Bots, die verstehen das, was ich sage, halbwegs und können dann drauf antworten.
Aber in dem Fall glaube ich es tatsächlich. Poggers. Ich mache mal kurz meine VM an,
dass ich meine VM updaten kann, weil wir verwenden Arch, by the way. Und Arch ist
Rolling Release und Rolling Release braucht ab und zu mal Update. Update-ge. Gibt es da
eigentlich ein Emote für? Update-ge. Emote? Nein. Update-ge. Gibt es da noch kein Emote für?
Das muss man eigentlich mal kreieren. Update-ge. Ich mache mal kurz, ich mache mal Update-ge.
Bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist, mache ich Update-ge. Oh, was ist hier los?
Ah ja gut, Update-ge halt. Oh nein, gleich ist mein Linux VM kaputt. Hab ich eigentlich
meine ganzen Snapshots gelöscht, wenn wir gerade dabei sind? Okay, es macht der hier.
Vom 4.2. bei der Installation habe ich noch einen Snapshot. Seriously. Ja, ganz wichtig.
Den brauche ich unbedingt noch. Furchtbar essenziell, dass ich den noch habe.
Wir machen heute weiter mit Setge-Servers zu White-Pepo-Happy-Servers. Vielleicht auch zu
Fetge-Servers. Nee. Manchmal erzähle ich random Zeug, was überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt. Das
fällt mir dann manchmal auf und ich denke mir, Max, das hat jetzt aber überhaupt keinen Sinn
ergeben. Close. Zack, Update ist durch. Dann machen wir noch mal schnell Update von allen
anderen Packages. Okay, wunderbar. Dann ist gut. Ja, erinnert mich dran, Leute. Falls ich es
vergesse, machen wir heute wieder. Pogu. Machen wir. So gegen Ende des Streams machen wir dann.
Okay, Pogas. Also, wir haben es geupdatet. Also eigentlich kann ich jetzt mal eine Runde
rebooten, weil war bestimmt Colonel-Update dabei. Wie das so ist, Colonel-Update muss man in der
Regel, ich sage in der Regel, weil es ist ja nicht immer so, es gibt ja schon Möglichkeiten,
Colonel-Updates so zu, naja, 80% Hotswap-mäßig zu machen, dass man nicht...
Warum ist, warum ist meine Status-Liste jetzt kaputt?
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, woran es liegt, das wissen wir mal kurz.
Kurz fixen und dann kann ich auch Chat gucken. Das liegt daran, dass ich... Wo ist es denn?
Das liegt daran, dass die Status-Liste irgendwie verbackt ist und... Wo liegt denn der Scheiß,
Mann? Ja, geil. Ja, das liegt daran, dass die Status-Liste
verbackt ist und ich die erst patchen muss für die aktuelle Python-Version. Da wollte
ich eigentlich ein Pullgequest bei dem Dude aufmachen, aber habe ich nicht gemacht. Ich
muss mal kurz gucken, wo liegt denn der Mist überhaupt? Ich guck gleich in den Chat, Leute.
FD. Müsste er doch finden. Ja, ist es doch. Da ist es doch. Ist alles gut. Da ist es
doch. So, und da müssten wir jetzt nämlich nicht Import-Lib machen, sondern Import-Lib-Util.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum, aber dann funktioniert es wieder. Ja, das ist kaputt, weil ich irgendwelche
krasse Module gebastelt habe dafür. Was zum Teufel ist Heaven? Will ich das wissen? Ach,
der Benchmark. Der Benchmark. Okay, jetzt verstehe ich es. Ja, so sieht es aus. Also,
okay, Chat. Ich habe mir ein paar Sachen übersehen. Also, was wird hier gemacht? Letztes
Mal habe ich schon erklärt, ich zeige es gleich. Okay, also ich zeige euch das. Wir
haben das letzte Mal eine Linux-Challenge gemacht oder eine Linux-DevOps-Challenge,
eine Linux-Administrator-Challenge oder was auch immer. Wobei, ich lese euch einfach
vor, was auf der Seite steht. Like-Lead-Code, ne, Like-Lead-Code for Linux, also sprich,
das sind Aufgaben, die man in einer gewissen Zeit erledigen muss, ansonsten formatiert
sich die VM von alleine. Es passiert nichts, wenn man die nicht in der Zeit erledigt. Aber
es gibt Aufgaben, guck hier zum Beispiel, es gibt Aufgaben von leicht bis schwer und
wenn du hier auf Run drückst, kriegst du einen Linux-Server in AWS mit einem Problem.
Das Problem ist, das Problem ist, keine Ahnung, das ist immer hier beschrieben. Ja, das muss
ich gleich wieder verstecken. Das Problem ist hier beschrieben, zum Beispiel, zu dieser
Zeit kann ich Google pingen und du musst rauskriegen, innerhalb von 20 Minuten, warum? Und wenn
du es geschafft hast, dann hast du es geschafft. Mehr gibt es dazu oder nicht? Wobei ich sagen
muss, die Dinge wurden tatsächlich zunehmend schwieriger. Das letzte Mal, also wir haben
angefangen hier oben ganz normal bei den ersten, also die ersten waren wirklich extrem easy,
für jemand, der das schon eine Weile macht. Da muss man nicht AWS-Kunde sein, ne ne, das
bezahlt der Seitenbetreiber hier alles und es kostet auch kein Geld. Deswegen kann man
glaube ich auch maximal 10 davon am Tag machen, wenn man will. Muss man nicht. Ein Beispiel,
ja, Beispiel. Ich zeige euch nochmal Stufe 1. Stufe 1 kriegt jemand, der ein bisschen
Ahnung von Linux-Administrationen hat in 2-3 Minuten ohne Probleme. Ach, 20 Sekunden ohne
Probleme hin. Ich zeige euch gleich nochmal als Beispiel Stufe 1, dass ihr wisst, dass
ihr wisst, um was es geht. Das letzte Mal haben wir gemacht Stufe 1 bis, oder was heißt
man, Aufgabe 1 bis inklusive Aufgabe 9, wenn ich mir das richtig gemerkt habe. Das heißt
als nächstes kommt das hier dann dran. Wir sind noch im Mittel, 2 weiter kommt dann, kommt
dann, wird es dann schwierig, wird es dann schwierig. Was ich cool finde an der Seite,
der erweitert das auch regelmäßig, guck mal hier, das gab es August 2022 und es gab
erst von paar Tagen, vor 2 Tagen, ganz neu, kam noch eine weitere Challenge dazu. Ja,
das kommt jetzt. Also es ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie solche Hacking-Webseiten,
wo es dann Aufgaben gibt so nach dem Motto, finde raus, was in dieser Datei steht oder
aus der Datenbank was auszulesen oder sowas in der Richtung, nur eben nicht so sehr für
Hacking-Content, beziehungsweise für teilweise so Programmier-Stell, sondern eher für die
andere Seite. Und da gibt es ja, also mir fällt nichts anderes ein. Ich finde das übrigens
eine sehr gute Idee, hätte es das früher schon gegeben, als wir noch viele Azubis hatten,
also so vor 3, 4 Jahren zuletzt dann, also vor 3 Jahren zuletzt, da hätte ich die mal
so ein paar solcher Dinge machen lassen. Allerdings hätte ich die nicht einfach nur machen lassen,
weil dann kannst du dir auch die Lösung im Internet raussuchen, die hätte mir dann auch
erklären müssen, warum sie was gemacht haben. Und wenn einer zufälligerweise exakt die Lösung
hat, so von der Info, das fällt ja auf, man merkt ja, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung von
der Sache hat, ob sich das jemand selbst überlegt hat oder ob irgendjemand was abgeschrieben
hat. Oh, die Katze hat mich gekratzt vorhin. Ich habe, da bin ich selbst dran schuld gewesen.
Ich habe mir der Katze, ich muss, ich war mit der Katze im Wohnzimmer und die hat, ich
habe ihr so einen Tunnel gekauft bei Amazon. Kennt ihr vielleicht so Tunnel, die rascheln
dann, wenn man die Katze durchrennt und diesen Tunnel findet die alleine ziemlich langweilig.
Wo die aber unglaublich drauf steht ist, wenn die sich hinter den Tunnel legt, also sowas
hier Amazon. Zu laut die Musik, was denn hier los? Raschel Tunnel, sowas habe ich der gekauft.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung hatte ich. Also ein bisschen andere Farbe und so. Obwohl die
halt total drauf steht, ist sich auf die Seite, da wo das Kaninchen oder was das ist, da drinnen
sitzt, dahinter zu setzen und das allein ist nicht spannend, dann muss irgendjemand an
die andere Seite gehen und davor wackeln und mit irgendwas wackeln. So und normalerweise
nehme ich dafür halt irgendwie so ein Stöckchen, so ein Wedel für die Katze, nur diesmal habe
ich es halt mit meiner Hand gemacht und die war halt sehr schnell, die hat sich halt gedacht,
oh guck mal, fette Maus am anderen Ende des Tunnels und ist, also ich habe die Hand noch
weggezogen, aber die ist dann meiner Hand hinterher gesprungen und hat es dran rumgemacht, weil
gut, die Maus ist halt vor ihr weggerannt. Die hat es dann schon gecheckt, die hat dann
auch gleich losgelassen, als sie mitgekriegt hat. Das ist keine fette Maus, das ist meine
Hand, aber dann war zu spät. Es ist jetzt wirklich schlimm, aber es tut ein bisschen
weh an der Seite, deswegen muss ich da ab und zu mal ein bisschen Spucke oder so drauf
schmieren, dass es heilt. Ja, so sieht es aus. Exzellent. So, ich sehe schon, ich muss
noch ein bisschen warten, bis der Stream richtig losgeht. Twitch hat es nach der initialen
Welle an Leuten an Twitch erst mal nicht mal gecheckt, weil das sehe ich immer daran,
wie viele Leute im Chat was schreiben. Die meisten Leute schreiben da, ich bin da und
hier und da gibt es wieder was, aber war ja gerade nichts. Deswegen warte ich noch mal.
Ich habe übrigens das ultimative Tool gefunden für alle Leute, die besonders weird champs
sein wollen. Also wenn ihr was mit Linux zu tun habt und wollt besonders weird champs
sein, dann müsst ihr euch mal dieses Tool hier angucken. Also wenn ihr besonders weird
champs sein wollt, dann müsst ihr euch dieses Tool angucken. Also ich habe es irgendwo auf
YouTube gesehen, es kann sein, ich bin mir nicht sicher wo. So, und das ist ein Tool,
wenn ihr Kommandos ausführt, die fehlschlagen oder nicht fehlschlagen, wirst du dann gelobt
oder zusammengeschissen. Also es gibt teilweise Tools, die hält man nicht für möglich, aber
die gibt es. Also der weird champ preis des Tages geht eindeutig an dieses Tool. Shell
Mommy. Man kann übrigens auch einstellen, dass sie einen nur anscheißt oder nur lobt
oder so, das geht auch. Und das Ding ist mittlerweile so advanced, es gibt dann auch verschiedene
Mods, dass dann deine Shell spricht wie Samuel L. Jackson und so Zeug. Frag mich nicht, was
mit den Leuten los ist, aber habe ich letztens in einem Video gesehen, dachte mir so, jetzt
muss ich euch mal zeigen, also richtig weird, weird, weird, weird champ. Angekabelter Champ
ist es schon. Ja, ich weiß nicht wer das wirklich benutzt, wozu, aber. Hey, ich weiß,
es gibt auch, es gibt auch, es gibt auch noch andere Tools, die tatsächlich was sinnvoll
ist, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ihr The Fuck kennt, auch ein sehr beliebtes Tool. 75.800
GitHub Sterne, das ist massiv viel. Der vier Champ, was ja natürlich selbstverständlich
das Maß aller Dinge ist. Der hat nur 48 Sterne. Also sieht man mal, wie beliebt das ist und
The Fuck macht Folgendes, wenn du dich verschreibst, dann sagst du Fuck und der versucht dann das
Kommando davor zu korrigieren. Wann vier Champ mit Rust gar nicht? Ganz ehrlich, bis
ich das alles in Rust gemacht habe, da sitze ich ja Monate. Rust ist schon nicht so flüssig
zu schreiben, wie sagen wir mal C-Sharp oder irgendwas anderes. Rust ist, Rust hat einen
hohen Rauschanteil finde ich und sieht auch nicht schön aus. Rust hat durchaus unbestreitbar
seine Vorteile, aber ich finde für Alltag Software eher weniger. Auch wenn das die Rust
Taskforce auf Hacker News anders sieht. Hab zu Hause im Homelab einen Proxmox Host mit
einigen VMs, auf denen verschiedene Services laufen. Bin gerade überlegen einen Storage
Server aufzubauen. Bin mir aber unsicher, ob Android oder Tuners. Hast du Erfahrungen
mit einer dabei im OS? Also ich kann dir sagen, geh nicht in das FreeNAS Forum, also das ist
das Forum von Tuners und FreeNAS und sag dort, du möchtest es virtualisieren und sag auch
auf gar keinen Fall, dass du es ohne ECC Rahmen betreiben willst, falls du es ohne ECC Rahmen
betreibst, weil dann rasten die aus. Es ist zwar überhaupt nicht schlimm, es virtualisiert
zu betreiben, es ist auch überhaupt nicht schlimm, es ohne ECC Rahmen zu betreiben,
die rasten aus im Forum. Die sind richtig weird champ. Ja, also Erfahrung habe ich mit
TrueNAS keine. Ich habe mal etwas FreeNAS verwendet vor deutlich längerer Zeit. Das
war okay. Ich habe dann aber für mich daheim keinen Anwendungszweck gesehen. TrueNAS muss
man allerdings sagen, TrueNAS ist jetzt glaube ich auch auf Linux Basis und FreeNAS war noch
auf BSD Basis. Und ich habe einen Android daheim, wobei ich die zwei Systeme gar nicht,
also ja, die haben gewisse Überschneidungen, wobei man sagen muss, dass es schon, außer
dass man bei beiden ein WebUI hat, um Samba Shares anzulegen zum Beispiel, nicht allzu
viel Gemeinsamkeiten gibt. Also, Android ist eher so die Low Budget Variante. Ach, TrueNAS
Scale ist Linux, ach so ist das. Und FreeNAS gibt es jetzt gar nicht mehr oder was? Okay,
seht ihr mal, ihr seht ihr, ich habe das schon eine ganze Weile, ich habe das schon eine
ganze Weile nicht mehr verfolgt. Ja, okay. Also, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau, also
ich habe Android im Einsatz, ich würde sagen, dass prinzipiell Android dazu tendiert eher
so ein bisschen die, ich meine das jetzt nicht eben, dass es nichts kann, sondern vom Preis
her so ein bisschen die Budget-Lösungen zu sein, weil du brauchst dafür nicht so viel
Hardware und du kannst das auch besser ausnutzen an Platten, die du hast. Du kannst in Android
zum Beispiel Platten mit unterschiedlicher Größe reinstecken und du musst dann auch
nicht darauf achten, dass du 85% Platz lässt und du kannst es auch einfacher erweitern
und sowas. Das ist mit ZFS drunter alles ein bisschen komplizierter, dafür hast du
halt die Vorteile von ZFS. So, also wie Snapshots und Überprüfungen automatisch, ob alles
noch lesbar ist und sowas. Du kannst ab der nächsten Android-Version dort auch ZFS mit
verwenden. Btrfs funktioniert jetzt schon, allerdings wie ausgereift das dann ist einmal
dahingestellt und ansonsten muss man sagen, neben der Nass-Funktionalität, also was ja
im Endeffekt eigentlich aus zwei Teilen besteht, ein bisschen Raid-Config über Skui und Samba-Shares
anlegen über Skui mit Usern. Das ist ja zum größten Teil die Nass-Funktionalität, also
viel mehr ist es ja nicht. Es reicht ja schon. Und allerdings kann Android mittlerweile sehr
viel mehr, Tuners kann glaube ich auch VMs und sowas, aber Android kann sehr viel mehr,
du kannst Docker-Container betreiben drauf, du kannst KVM-VMS drauf betreiben, alles
mit einem relativ netten UI. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut die Sache schon unter Tuners funktioniert
und wie das UI unter Tuners ist, keine Ahnung. Denke mal, VMs kannst du da auch drunter betreiben,
aber wie gesagt, ich habe Tuners ja nie ausprobiert, ich kann dir nichts zu sagen. So hundertprozentig
zufrieden bin ich ehrlich gesagt mit Android auch nicht, weil ich jetzt, ich hab's jetzt
ja ungefähr in einem Jahr oder so denke ich mal im Einsatz, so einiges wirkt schon ein
bisschen angefangen und nicht ganz fertig gemacht. Ja, so cool, also so cool das mit
den Plugins ist, geht auch öfters mal irgendwas kaputt oder wird nicht mehr so ported, so
cool das mit den VMs ist, so wirklich gescheit, alles Settings im Webinterface machen kannst
du doch nicht, und du hast große Probleme mit USB-Paths, wo manche Sachen gar nicht
richtig funktionieren. Was ich tatsächlich an Docker, was ich tatsächlich an Android
wirklich ganz cool finde, ist die integrierte Verwaltung von Docker-Containern, aber selbst
die ist aktuell ein bisschen kaputt, dass du Container nicht richtig updaten kannst.
Also ich muss sagen, es hat schon seine Vorteile versus ein selbst installierter Ubuntu-Server,
wo man alles selbst machen muss, gratis Webinterface und dass man sich um einige Sachen keine Gedanken
mehr machen muss ist gut, aber ein bisschen halbherzig ist es an einigen Stellen schon.
Und ich hab den Eindruck, den Android-Hersteller interessiert das auch alles nicht so großartig,
zum Beispiel gibt es seit drei, vier Versionen, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, kannst
du, bei manchen USB-Geräten kannst du die nicht richtig zur VM durchreichen. Und die
haben das nie adressiert, die haben sich da nie drum gekümmert, der Fix ist bei Android,
in dem Fall wie immer, ein Plugin zu installieren und darüber USB-Paths zu konfigurieren.
Dann geht's, aber ich denk mir halt so, ey, so essentielle Sachen wie USB-Geräte in der
VM weiterreicht, dafür solltest du auch kein Plugin brauchen. Also du kannst das im normalen
UI auch konfigurieren, aber dann geht's nicht. Zumindest bei manchen USB-Geräten. Also ich
bin ehrlich gesagt nicht richtig glücklich mit Android. Ich find's aber angenehmer,
gerade wenn man es daheim einfach nur nebenbei laufen hat, ich hab es ja immer geflamed,
ich hab es ja eine ganze Zeit lang geflamed und gesagt, so ein Scheiß, wer verwendet sowas,
ich hab mir einfach einen Ubuntu Server oder einen Debian Server daheim hingestellt, hab
die Sachen selbst gemacht, Docker Compose fall drauf, KVM, aber wirklich schön ist das auch
nett, wenn man die Sache einfach nur möglichst komfortabel und einfach benutzen will. Klar,
ich mein, ich hab, und das sag ich als jemand, der wirklich schon lange Erfahrung mit Linux
hat und eigentlich so die meisten Sachen auch ohne zu überlegen aus dem FF hinkriegt, aber
gerade Docker Compose Files von Hand ändern, was mir immer noch lieber ist als Portainer,
weil Portainer mag ich nicht. Und KVM, Handling von VMs ist auch eklig auf der Kommandozeile,
da musst du XML-Dateien editieren und weißt überhaupt nicht, wie das Zeug richtig aussehen
muss, da kannst du Wirtmanager nehmen, aber Wirtmanager ist kein Webinterface, sondern
Wirtmanager ist nur ein UI-Desktop-Programm, das kannst du zwar auf eine andere Linux-Kiste
initiieren, durch den du dich auf einen Server connecten, ich find's alles auch nicht so
toll, ehrlich gesagt. Deswegen hab ich dann gesagt, ok, im Heimbereich, ich will mich
ja möglichst wenig drum kümmern, will da möglichst wenig mitmachen und mich mit beschäftigen
müssen, soll einfach funktionieren, hab ich mir ein Android installiert, hab mir die kleinste
Lizenz gekauft, ordentlichen USB-Stick, hab dort jetzt eine Caching-SSD drinne, M2, 10G
Netzwerkkarte und 3, 12 oder 14 Terabyte Disks, nee, 2 Disks, 2 Disks, stimmt grad, oder?
3 Disks? Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht so ganz sicher, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich glaube,
2 Disks, weil eine hab ich noch dran zum Backup machen. Ja, das funktioniert, also die Basics,
so wie Samba-Shares und Freigamen machen und das Array stoppen und das ganze verschlüsseln
einen, das ist kein Problem, aber es ist einiges nicht so richtig zu Ende gedacht bei Unraid,
das heißt vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht probier ich echt mal Trunas aus, ich glaub,
das haben wir uns sogar oft aufgeschrieben, Trunas, Trunas Scale, ja, die Lebensvariante,
vielleicht probier ich das mal aus, vielleicht ist das vielleicht auch ganz nice. Ja, ey,
was war eigentlich die ursprüngliche Frage, ich hab jetzt ganz schön, ganz schön lang
erzählt, weil der Tag lang ist. Also, ich find Unraid nice, aber so richtig 100% nicht
zufrieden bin ich auch nicht mit, Trunas hab ich keine Erfahrung. Mal gucken, wie Trunas
ist. Was auch eine coole Sache wäre, es gab ja mal eine Zeit lang so ein Projekt, da konnte
man das Cynology Betriebssystem auf jeder x-beliebigen Kiste laufen lassen, ich glaub,
dort ist die Entwicklung auch ein bisschen langsamer geworden, weil Cynology da langsam
was dagegen hat, aber die Idee war grundsätzlich eigentlich ganz nice. Ja, genau. Das ist
tatsächlich ein großer, also, ich seh bei Unraid auch ein bisschen den Vorteil, wenn
man unterschiedlich große Platten verwenden will oder wenn man es mal einfacher erweitern
will. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie es mit dem Extending Support oder mit diesem
Extend, also, dass man sein Volume oder sein Pool, heißt das ja bei ZFS, erweitern kann,
wie das da aussieht. Also, in der ursprünglichen ZFS Variante, also die, die es auch noch unter
Solaris gibt, gab und da gab es das ja nicht mit Pool erweitern, aber mittlerweile gab es
dort Bestrebungen, das einzubauen, ZFS für Linux. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile
drin ist. Oder Expand Pool. Ja, Moment, du kannst den Pool jederzeit verändern, indem
du weitere Platten hinzufügst. Okay, das ist aber auch schon seit drei Jahren so, oder?
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mich mit dem Thema beschäftigt hab, war noch vor Corona und
da war es auch schon, das Feature ist fertig und wird jetzt bald gemurtscht. Anscheinend
geht das noch nicht. Ich rede nicht von Android, ich meine ZFS. Ich rede nicht von Android,
ich meine ZFS. Da geht das, mit Android funktioniert das, mit ZFS funktioniert das nicht. Mit ZFS
kannst du nicht so einfach deinen Pool erweitern, das einzige was du bei ZFS machen kannst ist
Platten erweitern. Was haben wir denn da noch auf? Keine Ahnung. Also es ist alles irgendwie
nicht so richtig der Weisheitsletzte, Schluss. Ja, ich weiß nicht, also sicher, früher ging
das nicht. Früher ging das Erweitern auch nicht unter Solaris und dem offiziellen ZFS.
Benutzt Android nicht ZFS? Ne, Android kann erst ab der nächsten Version offiziell ZFS
machen. Vorher nicht. Also mit Plugin nur, ja. Bei der nächsten Version ist es angeblich
dann mit drinne, aber da würde ich jetzt nicht so sehr drauf setzen, das ist die erste
Version, keine Ahnung wie gut die Verwaltung ist und ZFS ist ja schon ein relativ komplexes
Thema. Also das darf man auch nicht unterschätzen. Wenn jemand keinen Plan hat und er hat Probleme
mit ZFS, da hat er richtig Probleme. Weil wenn du eine normale Platte hast mit XFS oder X4,
die hängst du an irgendein X beliebiges Linux System dran und auf gehts, auslesen, fertig.
So, hast du eine ZFS Pool und selbst wenn du den mit, du bootest, keine Ahnung, du hast
dein Betriebssystem irgendwie zerlegt, aber du brauchst dringend Daten von einem Pool,
da kannst du natürlich über USB beispielsweise Proxmox booten oder aktuelles Ubuntu oder
sonst was mit ZFS Support und dein Pool da einhängen. Aber ernsthaft, ZFS Pool, also
ist natürlich von der Bedienung her bisschen komplizierter als einfach nur ein Filesystem
mounten mit X4. Du musst den Pool erstmal irgendwie enablen, dann musst du den Pool
irgendwie mounten, eventuell musst du dann auch gucken, dass deine ganzen, wie heißt
das, Datasets oder so an den richtigen Punkten hängen. Also es ist nicht so easy, wie einfach
eine Platte einhängen. Man muss sich erstmal mit ZFS ein bisschen beschäftigen. Also einfach
blind ZFS nehmen ist glaube ich keine allzu gute Idee. Dazu kommt, dass man bei ZFS auch
auf ein paar Sachen näher achten muss. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ja gut, wenn du es encrypted
hast, LVM und so drunter, wobei, ne, würde ich gar nicht mal sagen, würde ich gar nicht
mal sagen, also vielleicht mit LVM. LVM macht es unnötig kompliziert, weil du erst auch
das Logical Volume irgendwie enablen musst und dann aktivieren musst und bla, also das
ist eklig. Aber Lux einzuhängen und dann das File-System drauf zu mounten ist eigentlich
relativ easy. Das finde ich mit ZFS tatsächlich, wenn man sich auch gar nicht damit beschäftigt
hat, schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Und bei ZFS musst du auch auf mehr Sachen achten,
zum Beispiel, dass du deinen Pool nicht komplett vollmachst. Wie gesagt, ich habe das eine
ganze Weile nicht mehr verwendet, vielleicht gibt es da mittlerweile auch irgendwelche
Mechanismen. Also du musst darauf achten, dass du den Pool nicht vollmachst, weil sobald
der Pool einen gewissen Füllgrad erreicht, kriegst du wohl Performance-Probleme. Das
kann ich allerdings nur vom Hören sagen, die Probleme hatte ich nie, weil ich meinen
Pool nie so vollgemacht habe. Das Einzige, aber es gibt ein richtig heftiges Problem,
wenn du deinen Pool wirklich komplett vollmachst bei ZFS, da kannst du ihn glaube ich irgendwie
nicht mal richtig leer machen danach. Das ist ganz weird. Hatten Probleme hatte ich aber
auch nicht. Es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten, wie man das umgehen kann, indem man beispielsweise
irgendwie 0,1% als nicht belegbar definiert und solche Sachen. Aber man muss halt auch
erstmal dran denken und muss sich der Sache auch erstmal bewusst sein, dass das das das
Problem gibt. Steht bei Solaris, steht bei Solaris, dass du den Pool wirklich erweitern
kannst, zum Beispiel von 8TB Platten auf 10TB Platten und sowas, beziehungsweise dass du
nicht nur einfach das gleiche Layout erweitern kannst. Also früher unter ZFS war es so, du
kannst, wenn du einen Pool gemacht hast aus, sagen wir mal, du hast einen Raid, du hast
einen Raid 1,0 gemacht, so sinngemäß, was ist denn das dann bei ZFS? ZFS Raid, mach
keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf. Da konntest du es dann immer nur um exakt die gleiche Plattengröße
und Plattenanzahl erweitern. Und das war nicht so einfach, den Pool zu erweitern. Und umziehen
auf größere Festplatten war ein ganz großes Problem. Kann sein, dass das mittlerweile
alles funktioniert, aber das ist auf jeden Fall im Handling nicht so easy, wie ich kopiere
mal schnell meine Daten von XFS rüber oder von X4. Dafür hast du halt auch die ganzen
Vorteile von ZFS. Fängt schon an bei Snapshots und solchen Geschichten. Man muss sich einfach
im Forum viel mehr Gedanken machen. Wie ist das mit der ZFS-RAM-Thematik? Da muss man
darauf achten. Ja, ZFS, da gibt es eine Konfliktdatei, da gibt es eine Konfliktdatei, da steht drinnen,
wie viel Prozent des RAMs sich ZFS genehmigen soll. Das kannst du ohne Probleme im Heimbereich
runterdrehen. Also wenn du das Freenars-Forum fragst, das Freenars-Forum sagt dir so sinnloses
Sachen, wie ich kriege es, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich es aus dem Kopf noch
hinbekomme. Was sagen die? 1 GB RAM? Pro 100 GB oder so was? Sehr komische Empfehlung
auf jeden Fall. Die haben da ganz weird Champige Sachen. Nach dem Motto, wenn du nur eine Kiste
mit 32 GB RAM hast, dann musst du sie erst gar nicht betreiben. 1 GB pro Terrain? Doch,
das ist es glaube ich. Das könnte wahrscheinlich sein. Mindestens 1 GB. Das ist aber alles
letztendlich Blödsinn. Das macht natürlich Sinn als Pima-Daumen-Maßstab. Wenn man jetzt
vorhat, das vielleicht in der Firma als Fileserver einzusetzen, wo die ganze Nacht darauf gearbeitet
wird und es wirklich drauf ankommt, dass da irgendwie 50 Benutzer gleichzeitig oder
so was. Alles okay, aber nicht daheim. Also du kannst daheim das ohne Probleme runterstellen.
Du musst dir da keine 96 GB RAM-Kiste hinstellen, nur dass du ab und zu mal auf dein Samba-Share,
der dann unten drunter auf ZFS liegt, mal ein paar Files-Backupen kannst du darüber
kopieren. Das ist Blödsinn, das brauchst du nicht. Der Vorteil von viel RAM bei ZFS ist,
dass das gerne Sachen casht. Du kannst dann quasi die Sachen direkt in RAM feuern, wenn
du beispielsweise ein Netzwerk-Share hast und schreibst da drauf, dann feuert das erstmal
in RAM und wird dann im Hintergrund weggeschrieben. Ist halt ganz nice, brauchst keinen SSD-Cache
oder solche Geschichten, wobei das natürlich auch wiederum empfohlen wird. Wie gesagt,
ZFS ist komplette Wissenschaft für sich. Du hast ja bei ZFS irgendwie 2-3 verschiedene
Varianten, wie du cashen kannst. Du hast dann irgendwie so einen Index-Cache und du hast
so einen Write-Cache und du hast irgendeinen Metadaten-Cache und boah frag mich nicht,
keine Ahnung. Also ZFS ist richtig feifert, wenn man da durchblicken will. Ja genau, genau.
Dafür hast du halt coole Features, aber man muss halt auch an viel denken. Ich glaube für
die meisten im Heimbereich ist es gar nicht mal so sinnvoll, wie es vielleicht aussieht.
Weißt du, wie gut man ZFS Volumes erweitern kann? Ja da hatte ich es gerade von, eigentlich
gar nicht. Es sei denn, du baust die gleichen Platten in der mindestens gleichen Größe
dazu. So nach dem Motto, wir stecken mal eine 10TB Platte rein und erweitern das dann da
drüber, dass das funktioniert nicht. Also du musst, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht
mehr hin. Du kannst das schon erweitern, aber du musst glaube ich, oder ne, wie war das
denn nochmal? Ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin. Ich glaube du kannst es nicht erweitern,
du kannst quasi das gleiche, du kannst die exakt gleiche Config, die du hast, kannst
du nochmal dabei stecken und dann kannst du es quasi über beide drüber spannen. Irgendwie
so, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin. Ich hab nie den ZFS Pool erweitert. Es ist
auf jeden Fall nicht so einfach wie LV Extend, abgeh die Post. So einfach ist es nicht mit
ZFS. Ja und wo man auf jeden Fall drauf achten sollte, bei ZFS ist nicht Features einschalten,
von denen man keine Ahnung hat, weil, das hab ich auch noch im Hinterkopf, es gibt ZFS
Features, die kann man nicht mehr ausschalten, MonkaS. Also wer zum Beispiel glaube, D-Duplication
einschaltet, der hat gelitten, das kriegste nie wieder aus und D-Duplication ist auch
aus und D-Duplication frisst RAM as fuck, damit es performant ist und ist fraglich, ob man
das wirklich im Heimbereich auch haben will. Dann hast du glaube ich, ob man Compression
wieder ausschalten kann, weiß ich gar nicht. Also muss man aufpassen und ZFS kann ja mittlerweile
auch Verschlüsselung von Haus aus und das ganze wurde auch ziemlich pfeifherdig gelöst,
hab ich noch nie benutzt. Wir haben es glaube ich mal in einem Stream gemacht, stimmt gar
nicht. Wir haben es mal in einem Stream gemacht, vor 3 Jahren oder so, ich erinnere mich, guckt
mal hier. Wir haben mal einen Stream gemacht mit ZFS. Wieder da, hier, Booten von ZFS mit
Native-Verschlüsselung. Ok, der Stream war 18.11.2017, Leute. Das Stream ist 6 Jahre
her. Da war ZFS-Verschlüsselung noch ganz, ganz neu. Da haben wir das mal gemacht. Ja,
und das kann ich euch sagen, das war ein riesen Akt. Da haben wir damals versucht, da haben
wir mit ZFS, ich glaube sogar eine neue ZFS-Version kompiliert, weil ZFS-Verschlüsselung ganz
neu war damals und das Ziel war, Root zu verschlüsseln und davon zu booten. Und das war nicht einfach.
Da kann ich mich umdrehen, das war wirklich nicht einfach. Ohne Scheiß, wir können uns
wirklich mal wieder mit ZFS beschäftigen. Das haben wir schon. Wir können uns wirklich
mal wieder mit ZFS beschäftigen. Ist ja nicht verkehrt, weil man einfach ein bisschen durchblickt,
was da so abgeht, auch wenn man es nicht verwendet. Ja, wie gesagt, das ist alles schon ganz schön
lange her, wo ich mich damit beschäftigt habe. Also glaubt das dem Andreas eher als
mir, was man da ein ausschneiden kann. Ich hab da keine Ahnung mehr genau von. Brauchst
du ein Ceph-Cluster daheim? Ne, ich will es ja nicht übertreiben. Das ist ja eins, was
ich mir vorgenommen habe und seit ein paar Jahren schon versucht umzusetzen. Ich will
nur noch das sinnvolle, also nicht überall, aber dort, wo es auch wartungsintensiv ist,
nur die sinnvollen Sachen machen. Deswegen habe ich meine fette Server-Kiste auch ausgebaut,
habe jetzt eine kleine Kiste, dafür mir noch ein paar Raspberry Pis im Haus verteilt und
weniger Single-Point-of-Failures. Ich habe keinen PF-Sense bzw. Open-Sense-Router mehr,
ich habe einen ganz normalen billigen 50 Euro Mikrotik und sowas. Ist tatsächlich ganz
nice. Ich weiß, dass nicht alles zusammenfällt bei mir, wenn eine Kiste ausfällt. Auf der
anderen Seite ist es tatsächlich auch weniger wartungsintensiv, weil ich ab und zu halt
mal eine Kiste upgraden kann. Das interessiert nicht großartig und es ist auch einfacher
von der Komplexität her zu handeln und ich mache die Sachen bei mir daheim absichtlich
so simpel, wie es irgendwie geht mittlerweile. Ich weiß, dass man vieles vielleicht noch
ein bisschen besser automatisieren könnte oder besser optimieren könnte, aber es ist
halt die Sache, ich muss da in einem halben Jahr, wenn damit mal was ist, ja noch durch
blicken. Ist ja schön und gut, wenn ich jeden einzelnen Handschlag in dem Ansible-File
drinne habe. Das ist auch gut zum nachgucken, aber es hat die Frage, ob es den Aufwand rechtfertigt
daheim. Also muss ich wirklich jeden Furz, den ich vielleicht einmalig mache, alle 4-5
Jahre wirklich dafür, zum Lernen sage ich ja nichts dagegen. Wir haben ja im Stream auch
schon einiges uns angeguckt einfach so zu wissen, muss ich da wirklich Ansible-Playbooks
für erstellen oder Puppet-Profile oder sonst was. Zumal ich wahrscheinlich meine eigenen
Ansible-Sachen nach 2 Jahren angucke und denke, alter Max, was hast du da gemacht. Ich mache
das möglichst simpel, deswegen habe ich jetzt auch einen Unraid auf der Kiste hinten drauf
und nicht mehr meinen selbst installierten Ubuntu-Kiste. Ich habe mich ja immer lustig
gemacht über Unraid früher, aber wer verwendet so einen Blödsinn und ja, es ist nicht perfekt,
ich bin noch nicht hundertprozentig glücklich damit, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist die Verwaltung
ziemlich nicht vorhanden, was auch gut ist. Also die Maintenance ist quasi nicht vorhanden,
ich mache da so gut wie nichts dran. Es funktioniert halt, ich habe da 2 VMs drauf laufen und irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, 10, 12 Container. Ja, habe ich schon mal gehört, das ist irgendein, entweder
es ist ein NAS-Hersteller, aber ich glaube, es ist kein NAS-Hersteller direkt, die bauen
noch irgendwelche Storage-Kisten, die du dann an den Rechner anstöpseln kannst, oder?
Das ist nicht wirklich ein NAS, das ist doch eher so ein USB-Storage-Ding, oder? Ich habe
irgendwie einen Hinterkopf. 12 petabyte, ja, die Chia-Farmer haben auch ein bisschen gelitten,
weil das Problem ist, war keine so gute Idee, Chia zu farmen, würde ich sagen.
Da geht es nicht so richtig in die Stonks-Richtung. Es ist ein bisschen abgekackt. Dieses Krypto-Gelaber,
Alter, wenn ich das schon immer lese, alles, mann. Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo ich übertrieben
habe, wo ich aber eigentlich ganz froh bin, dass ich übertrieben habe. Ich habe ja seit
Jahren, wo das im Heimbereich noch nicht so verbreitet war, es ist heute im Heimbereich
immer noch nicht verbreitet, aber verbreiteter als damals, ich habe mir vor Jahren einen
ES16XG gekauft. Das ist ein Switch, der ist mittlerweile, das ist ja das Geile, der ist
nicht billiger geworden, der Switch die letzten Jahre über, der ist teurer geworden. Nein,
das ist der ES16XG. Aber man sieht es leider nicht weiter. Der ist teurer geworden. Ich
habe den damals, und wie gesagt, nicht inflationsmäßig teurer, der ist wirklich einfach nur krass
teurer geworden, auch schon bevor so Ultra-Inflationsstellen hier am Stand war. Kann man die Preisentwicklung
noch länger sehen bei Geizhals? Ja. Guck mal, ich habe den hier irgendwie gekauft, ja, irgendwie
so, würde ich sagen, in dem Dreh, für 500 noch Ebbers, und mittlerweile bezahlst du da
manchmal in Spitzen an die 700 für. Das Ding ist einfach immer teurer geworden, außer
hier zwischenzeitlich mal null. Ja, also das Teil habe ich mir vor einer Weile gekauft,
also vor 5, 6 Jahren, oder 2017, also ich glaube schon 6 Jahre, ja. Da bin ich tatsächlich
ganz froh, dass ich übertrieben habe mit dem Ding, weil so im Nachhinein bin ich alle
Sorgen in meinem Serverraum bzw. im Rack los, was irgendwie Switcher angeht. Ich habe da
einfach nur noch den und fertig. Ich meine, hey, es ist natürlich Overkill, die Kiste
hat, gibt's da vielleicht mal ein scheiß Bild von? Ja, okay, hier sieht man es halbwegs.
Die Kiste vorbei, Leute. Warum, warum auf Bilder zurückgreifen und nicht einfach, nein,
hier war ich noch am Umbauen, und nicht einfach den Switch selbst zeigen. Da ist er, naja,
wirklich viel. Das sieht man jetzt bei meiner krassen Aufnahmetechnik nicht. Ja, Keg-Wade,
weiß ich übrigens. Ja, hier sieht man es. Also der hat halt 12 SFP-Plus-Ports und 4
A45-Ports, also 12 10-Gigabit-Ports für Module und 4 10-Gigabit-A45-Stecker. Das ist aber
auch ganz gut, dass ich es da übertrieben habe, weil ich kann halt alles anschließen
von und das ist das Coole daran, deswegen habe ich mir den damals zwar nicht gekauft,
aber jetzt im Nachhinein bringt es das tatsächlich was, weil der macht natürlich auch abwärts
kompatibel 5 Gigabit und 2,5 Gigabit. Das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich, weil sich
das immer mehr durchsetzt und ich kann halt meinen Desktop-Rechner und meinen Storage
per 10 Gigabit anschließen und der Rest ist halt anderweitig angeschlossen. Ich hab mir
ein paar günstige Module gekauft. Kein Port, das ist ein Video, wo ich gerade umbaue, da
ist nichts angeschlossen. Guckt mal, das ganze Zeug, das wird gerade umgebaut in dem
Video. Da hängt ja auch nichts angeschlossen. Hier ist nichts dran gerade. Normalerweise
ist der fast, warte mal, lasst mich mal kurz reingucken, ich sag euch, wie voll der ist.
Zur Hälfte ist der voll. Also der ist aktuell. Mach mal ein Foto, da muss ich das jetzt uploaden
auf Imigur oder irgendwo hin, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf. Also ich kann euch sagen,
wie es aktuell aussieht. Also zur Hälfte voll, stimmt übrigens nicht, zur Hälfte
bestückt ist er. Voll in Form von, dass da was angeschlossen ist. Switch. Und wo war
man denn jetzt hier? Wo ist er denn? Da ist er. Der Switcher ist da. Also, die hier sind
alle belegt, einfach weil es am einfachsten ist. Die sind alle belegt, die AI45 Stecker
und der restliche Switch ist zur Hälfte bestückt mit, lass mal überlegen, wie war das angeschlossen?
Ich glaube, ja. Also hier müssten zwei Direct Attached SFP Plus Module drin stecken. Das
eine geht zum Switch hier neben auf dem Basteltisch, den kennt ihr. Habt ihr auch schon gesehen
den Switch. Das andere ist, ne drei, drei, blödsinn, blödsinn, blödsinn. Einer für
den Desktoprechner, einer für den Bastel-Switch und einer für den Fileserver. Ja. Sekunde.
Ok. Genau, also drei SFP Plus Ports sind hier belegt. Hier oben stecken Module drinnen,
allerdings, die hab ich mir mal super billig gekauft. Da gab es bei, ähm, also es war
nicht Amazon oder so, bei irgendeinem. Doch, ich weiß es wieder. Das war bei Amazon, das
war bei Amazon, aber es war nicht bei Amazon. Es war bei Amazon, allerdings war das von
irgendeinem Hardware-Teile-Shop und der hat mal einen 10er-Pack angeboten. Das könnten
sogar FS-Com-Module gewesen sein. Ja, der hat einen 10er-Pack angeboten. SFP-Module,
also SFP-Module sind die 1 Gigabit und SFP-Plus sind die 2 Gigabit-Module, äh, 10 Gigabit-Module,
die 2 Gigabit-Module, genau die. Also, SFP-Plus sind die 10 Gigabit-Module und SFP sind die
1 Gigabit-Module. Da hab ich mir mal einen 10er-Pack gekauft, 1 Gigabit-Module und ich
hab auch noch ein paar, äh, also, einen 10er-Pack SFP auf RJ45 1 Gigabit-Module. So viel, so,
so muss ich es richtig sagen. Die waren super billig, ich glaub 50 Euro oder sowas für
10 Stück oder 45,99 oder so, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Rückläufer oder so. Und deswegen
hab ich jetzt an 3 der Ports hier oben tatsächlich ganz normal 1 Gigabit dran. Das eine geht
dann irgendwie zum, zum Router runter und das andere geht, ach, keine Ahnung, ins Wohnzimmer,
das stimmt gerade, ins Wohnzimmer geht, da geht noch eins runter ins Inkeller, ins Erdgeschoss
und sowas. Wo ich die gekauft hab, ich hab die bei Amazon gekauft, bei irgendeinem Hardware-Shop,
der über Amazon verkauft, also nicht direkt bei Amazon, bei irgendeinem Marketplace-Dude
und er hat damals ein 10er-Pack-Module, ach, heute kein Senf, verstehe, Lumo, warum nicht?
Was ist, was ist, ist der Senf, ist der Senf-Fetisch irgendwie vorbei? Ich hab mir eigentlich vorgenommen,
wenn der Lumo heute in den Stream kommt, ich erzähl ihm, was ich lieber mag, welche Senf-Sorte,
aber heute interessiert ihn das nicht mehr, wisst ihr mal, so, so, so wird man enttäuscht
von den Leuten. Ja, okay, weiter, bevor wir mit den Servern anfangen, das will ich jetzt
auch fertig erzählen, genau, also, deswegen, ich benutze da vorne ein paar Ports nicht
als SFB-Plus-10G-Ports, sondern als ganz normale 1-Gigabit-Ports, aber das Schöne ist, dass
man dadurch eben so die Flexibilität hat, ich brauch halt nix anderes an Switchen mehr,
da unscheinlich muss ich sagen, ein weiterer 4-Port-10G-Switch, den hab ich nicht im Einsatz,
der liegt einfach nur rum, und das ist wirklich sehr praktisch gewesen, dass ich mir den damals
gekauft hab, also es hat sich tatsächlich gelohnt, auch wenn es erstmal bescheuert ausgesehen
hat, 2016 oder so, sich 10G-Switch mit insgesamt 16 Ports hinzustellen, war aber ganz sinnvoll.
Ja, sehr nice, auf jeden Fall, und was ich dort gemacht hab ist, ich hab den Lüfter
gemoddet, haben wir das nicht sogar im Stream gemacht, Leute, wir haben so viel Krempel
schon im Stream gemacht, wir haben das im Stream gemacht, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass
wir das im Stream gemacht haben, hier, da ist es doch, Ubiquiti-Switch-Lüfter-Mod, Moment,
das ist ein Clip, den Stream gibt es nicht im Archiv, weiß nicht warum, aber es gibt
noch ein paar Clips davon, hat das Archiv anscheinend irgendwie verschluckt, es gibt
noch ein paar Clips davon, wo wir in den, ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich gemacht
hab, genau, ja, da gab es zum 3D-Trucken für den Switch, das ist übrigens der 10G-Switch,
den ihr da oben seht, der hat, da hab ich bei Thingiverse so Adapter gefunden zum 3D-Trucken,
weil, jetzt kann ich mich wieder dran erinnern, jetzt kann ich mich wieder dran erinnern,
also, die Lüfter sind so ein ganz komischer Formfaktor hier hinten, so Lüfter findest
du normalerweise gar nicht, außer es sind halt die offiziellen Lüfter, aber es gab
nur einen Adapter, das sind irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das sind irgendwie 18,7mm Lüfter oder
irgendwas komisches gewesen, was es normalerweise nicht gibt, so und da ist jemand auf die glorreiche
Idee gekommen, man könnte doch einfach einen Adapter bauen, quasi so ein Mini-Lüfter-Kanal
von diesem komischen Mini-Lüfter-Format von dem Switch auf ein ganz normales Lüfter-Format
und da hab ich mir ein Noctua-Lüfter gekauft, was ist denn, was ist der kleinste Noctua-Lüfter,
den es gibt?
Den hab ich mir gekauft.
Okay, hat keinen Bock aufzugehen, die Seite, Leute, ich glaube jetzt, Flashbang, da geht
doch eigentlich halbwegs, es ist nicht ganz so schlimm, die Seite, was ist der kleinste
Noctua, den man sich kaufen kann, 40, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, die gibt's noch kleiner,
die gibt's noch kleiner, das ist kein 40mm, der da reinpasst, Pens, das ist wirklich das
kleinste, nie im Leben ist das das kleinste, da gibt's noch, das glaub ich nicht, wir haben
doch da, was haben wir da für Lüfter reingemacht, erkennt man das in dem Clip noch?
Natürlich nicht, das waren die Lüfter, die da drinnen waren, oder, ja, das waren die
Lüfter, die eingebaut gewesen sind, diese komischen, und eingebaut, Mensch, das interessiert
mich jetzt, das muss ich mal kurz, meinst du, das war ein 40er, ja, man sieht's hier
leider auch nirgendswo, vielleicht haben wir noch Glück, und es ist hier drinnen, schreiben
Leute eigentlich Kommentare, ne, oder, wenn schon wahrscheinlich, ne, ok, dann keine Ahnung,
vielleicht sind es auch 40mm, kein Schimmer, vielleicht sind es auch 40mm, vielleicht
sind es auch 40mm, die wir reingemacht haben, zumindest, habe ich dann diese Kabelkanäle
ausgedruckt, Kabel, Kabel, äh, nicht Kabelkanäle, meine Güte, Lüfter, Lüfteradapter ausgedruckt,
und da haben wir, ja, das war cool hier, das ist dieses, guck dir mal, das ist übrigens
auch was, was ich sehr empfehlen kann, leider gibt's den Stream anscheinend nicht mehr,
was ich sehr empfehlen kann, äh, so Inserts für 3D-gedruckte Teile, guckt euch das mal
an, du setzt, man setzt das da oben drauf, und dann nimmt man den Loot-Column, falls man
das hier, falls man das hier ordentlich sieht, was auch immer ich da mit der Zange will,
keine Ahnung, dann nimmt man den Loot-Column, und dann schmilzt man das, wenn man das richtig
trifft, dann schmilzt man das dort rein in das 3D-gedruckte, und wenn das, dann, okay,
ja, gut, und wenn das dann abkühlt, und wenn das dann abkühlt, ist das bombenfest, und
ihr könnt was ordentlich drinnen verschrauben, das ist eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich praktisch,
so ein Set, kostet doch nicht viel, bei Amazon, ja, und damit hab ich die Lüfter gemordet,
das heißt, ich hab jetzt in meinem Switch noch Tour-Lüfter drinnen, die sogar wahrscheinlich
besser kühlen als die anderen kleinen und leiser sind, nee, SFP ist nicht zwangsläufig
Glasfaser, was hat der denn hier jetzt, SFP ist nicht zwangsläufig Glasfaser, denn, ich
beantworte mal schnell die anderen Sachen, bevor wir mit den Servern anfangen, der Switch
durfte auch schon viel mit dem arbeiten, der MikroTik ist auch nice, ja, ja, vielleicht
würde ich, vielleicht würde ich mir heute auch, aber der MikroTik hat keinen AJ45 Stecker,
falls man das braucht, weil, wenn du AJ45 Stecker brauchst, und du 10 Gigabit Module
haben willst, dann wird's wahrscheinlich sogar teurer sein, weil 10 Gigabit Module auf AJ45
sind nicht billig, da würd ich sagen, kostet 40 Euro das Stück oder so, ja gut, nicht ganz
so teuer muss es vielleicht, wenn man guckt, aber das ist tatsächlich nicht ohne, ja, ansonsten
wenn man rein mit SFP Plus auskommt, oder wenn man Kupfer auch nur Gigabit bräuchte
eventuell, dann kann man das natürlich machen, aber ansonsten, du siehst ja schon am Preis,
lohnt es sich, wenn man wirklich Kupfer braucht, Kupfer sagen wir mal für 10, 5 oder 2,5, dann
bist du wahrscheinlich tatsächlich mit dem ES16XG noch irgendwie besser dabei, ja, aber
die MikroTik Dinger sind auch ganz nice, ich finde die Kombi aus 12 SFP Plus und 4 Gigabit
und 4x Kupfer Ports eigentlich ganz gut, was war eigentlich mit der USB, meine die hast
du rausgeworfen, ja die hab ich rausgeworfen, wisst ihr auch warum, weil die USB absoluter
Schrott war, und zwar warum war die Schrott, weil wie bei allen USBs nach längerer Zeit,
die Batterie kaputt gegangen ist, das ist okay, das ist okay, das sag ich nichts dagegen,
nach ein paar Jahren von so einer USB, darf die Batterie durchaus mal den Geist aufgeben,
wobei man dazu sagen muss, das sind ja alles keine Online-USBs, wo permanent der Strom
durchgeht, sondern alles so, wie heißt das Line Interactive oder so, die das, nee Passive,
doch Line Interactive heißt das glaube ich, die dann quasi nur umschalten, wenn auch wirklich
der Strom weg ist, und zumindest war die Batterie kaputt, und die Batterie, das ist ja so ein
Cyber-Power Ding, kann man auch in der Config nicht umstellen, wenn die Batterie defekt ist,
dann geht alles aus, was richtig hängen geblieben ist, ich will noch nicht, dass eine USB, wenn
die Batterie kaputt geht, und der Strom noch da ist, dass die Geräte, die da dran angeschlossen
sind, ausgehen, ich will, dass die USB, meinetwegen eine Warnung sagt, hallo die Batterie ist weg
und beim nächsten Stromausfall hast du dann gelitten, aber ich will noch nicht, dass die
USB die Outputs ausschaltet, obwohl der Strom noch da ist, nur wenn die Batterie kaputt
ist, also richtiges Dreck, absolut bodenloser Drecksprodukt ist das, der einzige Ausfall,
den ich all die Jahre hier mit meinem Rack hatte ist, als die Batterie in dieser Cyber-Power
USB kaputt gegangen ist, die habe ich rausgeschmissen, also ganz ehrlich, wir haben so selten Stromausfall
hier in den Regionen, dann nehme ich lieber den Stromausfall in Kauf, wie einen sicheren
Ausfall alle 4 Jahre, wenn die Batterie mal wieder den Abgang macht, und ich habe mir
tatsächlich was anderes gekauft, ich habe mir eine billige APC-USB gekauft und ich habe
darauf geachtet, das ist übrigens ein Trick, wenn ihr rausfinden wollt, wie sich eure
USB verhält, also sprich, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist, wie die sich verhält, das erkennt
man nämlich auf der Herstellerseite, nicht immer gut, Cyber-Power schreibt das auch nicht
so direkt rein, wenn man aber genau nachguckt, steht es da, dass die Geräte ausgehen, richtig
hängen geblieben, also der einfachste Fall, rauszubekommen, ob eure USB auch so doofes
Teufel macht, wie meine ist, guckt, ob die Batterie hot-swappable ist, wenn nämlich
die Batterie hot-swappable ist, also wenn ihr die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb austauschen
könnt, dann schaltet es logischerweise die Geräte nicht aus, wenn die Batterie kaputt
ist, weil ihr könnt die Batterie rausziehen, es läuft alles weiter, also wenn es hot-swapp-kann,
die USB, was übrigens so gut wie jede APC-USB kann, ist das kein Problem, das habe ich auch
schon ausprobiert, ich habe Kiste angeschlossen, Batterie rausgezogen, ging weiter, dann wieder
reingesteckt, USB macht Piep, Piep, Piep und Batterie wieder erkannt, alles gut. Ja,
so sieht es aus, hot-swapp bei der USB, ihr müsst allerdings trotzdem ein bisschen aufpassen,
wenn ihr die Batterie anschließt, ich sage es nur, das ist alles zwar relativ safe, aber
also bei den APC-USBs würde ich sagen, wenn man nicht aufpasst und irgendwie da im Gehäuse
rumfingert, ohne genau zu gucken, dann kann es passieren, dass man an den Pluskontakt
von der Batterie kommt, weil man drangegriffen hat, wo der Kontakt frei ist und das tut dann
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weh. Das sind glaube ich nur 24V Batterien oder sowas, also
ihr sterbt da wahrscheinlich nicht dran, außer ihr habt anderweitig irgendwelche Probleme,
aber es wird wahrscheinlich wehtun oder 48V Batterien, weiß nicht was da reinkommt, wahrscheinlich
nichts, wo gerade ihr sterben werdet, aber es tut auf jeden Fall weh, also so richtig
safe gelöst ist das nicht, es ist aber trotzdem ganz gut gemacht, also wenn man aufpasst,
passiert einem bei Batteriewechsel nichts. Also das ist auch soweit isoliert alles und
die haben die Kabel auch unterschiedlich lang gemacht, dass du auf jeden Fall zuerst das
Ground Kabel anschließen musst, bevor du das andere anschließen kannst, also wenn
du ein bisschen aufpasst, passiert dir nichts, aber wenn du blind im Gehäuse rumfingert,
dann wird es wahrscheinlich wehtun. Ja und deswegen, ich habe eine ganz billige APC-USB
jetzt dran, damit läuft das Rack wahrscheinlich auch nur, keine Ahnung, 10 Minuten oder so,
aber das interessiert mich nicht, es reicht ja zum runterfahren und die meisten 10 Minuten
sind ja Stromausfälle, die meisten Stromausfälle sind ja wirklich nur ganz kurzes Geruckel.
So viel dazu. SFP ist Glasfaser, wie lang dürfen da die Kabel sein? Nein, SFP ist nicht
zwangsläufig Glasfaser oder SFP Plus ist auch nicht zwangsläufig Glasfaser, gucke
mal da, Amazon, du kannst auch ein SFP Plus Direct Attach Kabel kaufen, was die mit Abstand
billigste Variante ist, also die USB, ich gucke nach, welche USB ich gekauft habe, Amazon,
sag da gleich was zu, wir haben Zeit, wir machen heute nur 2-3 Linux Server-Dinger, wir können
auch ein bisschen schwätzen und dann machen wir was ordentliches. Hier, ich habe eine,
was ist das für eine? Wo sieht man das jetzt? View Order Details, ok, angeblich ist das
eine APC UPS Pro BR650MI, exquisiter Name, oh mein Auge, wie jetzt, so ist besser, so,
so, so ein Teil ist das, hat einen USB Anschluss, USB Anschluss ist wichtig, dass die Rechner
mitbekommen, gar kein USB, ja doch, da kommt dann ein USB Kabel dran auf der anderen Seite,
also du kannst auslesen vom Rechner, wie viel Ladung da drauf ist, genau, das ist keine
19 Zoll, das ist so eine ganz billige, vom Hochkant reinstellen, aber die ist schon recht
tief, da muss ja die Batterie reinpassen, aber die kann ich super, neben das Rack stellen,
zwischen Rack und Wand oder unten reinlegen, das ist überhaupt kein Ding, das funktioniert,
wobei ich habe die aktuell hochkant neben dem Rack stehen, ich gucke mal, ob es ein
Video gibt dazu, wo einer die Batterie changet, oder ein Akku, Akku Change, hier Replacing,
da sieht man es doch, Alter, was für Musik, Alter, der Dude tauscht die Batterie von der,
der Akku von der USB, du denkst jetzt kommt die nächste Quickscope Montage oder sowas,
das ist bestimmt ein Ende oder, gleich kommt der Microsoft Support, so ähnlich sieht das
aus, das ist anscheinend noch der Vorgänger, das ist anscheinend noch der Vorgänger, meiner
hat ja noch ein bisschen mehr, wobei ich glaube, bei meiner ist ja noch ein BR davor, BR, das
MI bezieht sich übrigens auf die Anschlüsse hinten, MI sind diese Anschlüsse, es gibt
dann auch noch Kona Anschlüsse und hast du nicht gesehen, so also der Batteriewechsel
funktioniert folgendermaßen, nein, nein, nein, das muss, ich muss nicht aufschrauben,
nein, ich muss die nur vorne rausziehen, ich muss die nicht aufschrauben, ok, das stimmt
nicht, ok, keine Ahnung, aber hier vielleicht, ich will nicht, nein, nein, ich muss meine
nicht aufmachen, ich muss bei mir vorne, ich muss bei mir vorne einfach nur das rausziehen,
ja hier sieht man es, genau, das ist ja die gleiche nur ein bisschen größer, hier, so
sieht das Ding aus, das funktioniert auch anders, Moment, nee, nee, ich glaube, das
ist richtig, ich glaube, das ist richtig, ja bei mir ist aber nur eine Batterie drinnen,
genau, genau, stimmt, das ist nicht vorne, wo du es rausziehst, das ist an der Seite,
wo du es rausziehst, genau und du musst eigentlich nichts machen außer die Batterie mit ein bisschen
Kraft da rausziehen, easy, so und hier neben, man sieht es jetzt nicht richtig, hier neben
passiert normalerweise nichts, wenn du nicht aufpasst, könntest du aber an Kontakt von
der Batterie kommen, ja, ja, fummel da nur dran rum, wobei jetzt sind ja die Dinger ab,
so und wenn du die neue nimmst, ach der muss einfach nur reinstecken, normalerweise muss
man die nämlich noch anschließen danach, dann ist es da ein bisschen anders, also ich
muss bei meiner Batterie noch einen kleinen Stecker reinstecken neben, ja gut, egal, habt
das gesehen, so jetzt kommen wir zurück zu dieser Frage hier, Glasfaser, also was du
machen kannst, bei SFP und SF4 Plus Modulen gibt es zwei verschiedene Varianten, du musst,
du kaufst dir entweder Module, Module sind dann entweder welche, wo du Glasfaser, also
Module sind welche, die auf der einen Seite diesen Stecker haben, dass die da reinpassen
und auf der anderen Seite haben sie entweder einen AJ45 Stecker, wenn es so ein Konverter
ist oder einen, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, LC, SC, MC, wie heißen diese komischen
Anschlüsse, LC Stecker, ja einen LC Stecker, meistens zumindest, einen LC Stecker, so einen
da, der andere Stecker kriegst du allerdings an SFP Plus Modul nicht ran oder, wie willst
du einen, wie willst du einen SC Stecker an SFP, Moment, wie willst du einen SC Stecker
an allen SFP Plus Modul dran kriegen, also ich kenne nur Module, durchaus möglich, hier
sieht man den Stecker Vergleich, ich kenne nur Module mit diesen Steckertypen für Glasfaser,
es gibt SFP Plus Module mit, wie soll das funktionieren, also, Moment, sind jetzt LC
die Kleinen oder SC die Kleinen, ach Single, ok, das leuchtet mir wieder ein, dass es da
nur eine Faser ist und nicht doppelt, ja ok, das stimmt, ok, das kann ich mir vorstellen,
so also das ist das eine, du kaufst dir ein Modul, wo du entweder Glasfaser dran anschließt
oder ein 45 Stecker oder, was für den Heimbereich voll und ganz ausreichend ist und meistens
auch geht, von der Länge her ist, du kaufst dir ein Direct Attach Kabel, Direct Attach
Kabel ist quasi Kupfer, ein Kupferkabel mit SFP oder SFP Plus Steckern dran, die gibt
es glaube ich bis zu 10 Meter, ja dann Active, ok, danach ist es glaube ich schwierig, ich
weiß nicht, ob man das, ob man, Direct Attach mit 15 Meter, ob es das noch geht, weil irgendwann
ist auch mal Schluss, wie lang das geht, ja, also da muss man ein bisschen gucken, das
geht nicht, das geht nicht so lang wie ein normales AIR 45 Netzwerk Kabel, also du kannst
da keine 100 Meter mit überbrücken, mit so einem Direct Attach Kabel, aber das ist die
mit Abstand billigste Variante, weil du brauchst keine Module und du bekommst quasi ein 10
Meter Kabel für 38, kriegst du bestimmt noch billiger, für 38 Euro und du hast da schon
zwei Module quasi dran zum reinstecken, also das ist, wenn du nah genug dran bist, die
mit Abstand, die einfachste Variante, SFP Stecker zu benutzen daheim, Stockwerke zu
verbinden, ne, das liegt ja allein schon darin, weil du meistens ja so, du müsstest ja sowas
in der Wand liegen haben irgendwie, keiner hat einen Direct Attach Kabel in der Wand,
du hast vielleicht ein paar Glasfaserkabel in der Wand, aber kein Direct Attach Kabel,
dann ist es vielleicht aber immer noch sinnvoller, wenn du Stockwerke verbinden willst, je nach
dem, wenn du einen Switch hast, der AIR 45 Stecker hat, oder du kaufst ja halt wirklich
Module, das ist auch kein Ding, also die Module muss man immer gucken, ich würde es nicht
unbedingt bei Amazon kaufen, guck mal, was war das, fc.com, ne, oh, das ist was anderes,
ne, wie hießen die, ach fs, nicht fc, genau, wie viel kostet denn da sowas, industrielles
AFP plus selbstverständlich, industriell brauchen wir das, das geht dann schon ein
bisschen billiger.
Da sind aber die falschen, ne, die falschen, zumindest müsst ihr meistens keine offiziellen
vom Hersteller kaufen, also gerade die Cisco-Dinger sind übertrieben teuer, auch die Ubiquiti-Dinger
sind übelst teuer, die Mikrotik-Dinger waren eine Zeit lang relativ günstig, die sind aber
auch mittlerweile im Preis angezogen, die gab es mal relativ günstig, aber mittlerweile
ist es ja auch, guck mal, mittlerweile sind die auch viel zu teuer, ja, aber das ist die
Sache, was du mit Netzwerk machen kannst, glaub, müssen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter angucken,
ich glaub, soll es mehr oder weniger, hab ich jetzt eigentlich alles beantwortet.
Kriegste bestimmt bei Amazon auch.
Wieso steigst du nicht auf Linux um?
Die meisten Probleme können sich lösen lassen, indem man sich ne GP, haha, also so einfach
ist das nicht, mit GPU passt du vor M, da hast du andere Probleme, das ist nicht, dass
damit alles auf einmal besser ist, das fängt ja schon damit an, dass wenn du, ich will
es jetzt nicht zu sehr ausweiten, aber das fängt ja schon damit an, wenn du GPU passt
zu machst, wie bekommst du dann, ich weiß, dass es für alles da irgendwie Möglichkeiten
gibt, wie bekommst du dann deine Tastatur und deine Maus in die VM, das ist ja schon
mal das erste, du willst die in der VM benutzen oder willst die im House benutzen, wie machst
du das gescheit, das nächste ist, du brauchst da theoretisch einen zweiten Monitor, ich
weiß, dass du den nicht brauchst mit Looking Glass und was es nicht alles gibt, aber so
ganz optimal ist das auch nicht, wenn du es wirklich optimal mit der niedrigstmöglichsten
Latenz nutzen willst, dann brauchst du einen zweiten Monitor, weil du hast eine Grafikkarte
in deinem Host und du hast eine Grafikkarte quasi dediziert in deiner VM, du hast quasi
zwei Rechner mit zwei Grafikkartenausgängen, du brauchst theoretisch zwei Monitore oder
musst dein Monitor jedes Mal umschalten, also schön ist das nett, ich finde die Handhabung
von Linux in der VM und Windows als Host einfach für meinen Anwendungszweck überlegen,
weil wenn ich die Performance brauche für, sagen wir mal, Spiele spielen, da muss ich
mir überhaupt keine Gedanken machen, da mache ich Steam an, da mache ich GOG an, da mache
ich meinetwegen Dings hier, die EA App an und was es alles für Launcher gibt, ich kauf
mir das Spiel am Tag wo es rauskommt, ich installiere das, ich starte das und ich weiß,
dass es mit bestmöglicher Latenz, mit bestmöglicher Kompatibilität und so gut wie möglich einfach
läuft und das hast du unter Linux in der VM nicht, äh nicht, das hast du unter Linux
mit Wine und Proton nicht und in der VM hast du andere Probleme, ja gut, das liegt am Game,
das wäre aber unter Linux in der VM beziehungsweise unter Linux mit Wine und so wahrscheinlich
noch schlimmer gewesen, also das ist in der Regel das Problem, die problemloseste Variante,
wenn du es einfach unter der Plattform spielst, wo du es haben willst oder wofür es gemacht
ist, du kannst das lösen mit GPU, passt zu, kannst du vieles lösen, aber wie gesagt USB
Geräte durchreißen ist ein Problem, mehrere Monitore, Ausgänge ist ein Problem, es gibt
da noch, es gibt da ein paar Tricks für alles mögliche, aber dann musst du wieder sehr
viel basteln und es gibt ja auch überhaupt keinen Grund das ganze zu machen, weil es
gibt kaum was was ich nicht in meiner Linux VM machen kann und der Betriebssystemwechsel
so einfach von Windows zu Linux ist es mit einer GPU passt du vor einem definitiv nicht,
so seamless, hier, das kannst du nicht machen mit einer GPU passt du vor einem was ich hier
mache, Windows, Linux, das geht nicht, du kannst so Sachen wie Looking Glass verwenden,
du kannst dann dich vielleicht der Sache annähern, aber ganz im Ernst, dann sind wir halt wieder
so bei der ideologischen Frage, will ich Hardcore unbedingt nur Linux verwenden, weil ich einen
Richard Stallman Poster oder so über dem Bett hängen hab oder will ich das nutzen was
für mich am besten funktioniert und am einfachsten ist, das kann man so pauschal nicht beantworten,
das muss sich letztendlich jeder selbst überlegen was ihm da mehr wert ist, aber für mich
ist die Lösung die bessere Variante, mit macOS brauchst du das alles nicht, das stimmt
unter macOS laufen überhaupt keine Games, da hast du das Problem nicht mehr, geht einfach
gar nicht und außerdem Leute außerdem ist es ja auch GNU Linux bitteschön, sonst gibt
es Ärger, ja das stimmt das kannst du machen, aber nachdem die USB nehme an meiner Kiste
steht, kein Ding, die hab ich da angeschlossen und ich krieg das überwachungstechnisch mit
wenn da Strom ausfällt von der USB, so ich glaub jetzt haben wir's mit dir, das machen
wir jetzt, wollen wir jetzt, AOC das hab ich noch nie gehört, kenn auch das A-Cock Visier
aufs Cot, aber AOC hab ich noch nie gehört, also eins hab ich schon gehört, wenn es zu
dem Thema Glasfaserkabelspleißen muss richtig abartig sein, ich bin gerade am überlegen
ob mir das jemand erzählt hat oder ob ich das einfach nur im YouTube Video gesehen hab,
ich glaub ich hab's einfach nur im YouTube Video gesehen und zwar da hat jemand berichtet
der irgendwie 20 Jahre oder so bei einem Provider arbeitet, allerdings nicht wie ich so Sesselfurzer
mäßig beim Provider gearbeitet hab, ich mein ich hab ja beim Provider nicht wirklich
so die Hardcore Netzwerk Verlege Sachen gemacht, ja ich hab Server ein und ausgebaut und
solche Geschichten, ich hab im Rechenzentrum geguckt ob alles passt, ich hab dort ein paar
Kabel gepatcht und ich hab Linux administriert und sowas damals, aber ich hab nicht so die
Hardcore Wartungsarbeiten gemacht am Netzwerk selbst und ich hab, es gehört in einem YouTube
Video von einem, relativ sicher war das ein YouTube Video, ich glaub nicht, ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob es mir nicht vielleicht sogar einer erzählt hat, aber ich glaub es
war ein YouTube Video, der hat gesagt der arbeitet jetzt über 20 Jahre bei einem Provider und
ist für Netzwerk Wartungsarbeiten zuständig und die müssen auch regelmäßig Glasfaserkabel
spleißen und das müssen dann wohl auch ein bisschen dickere Kabel sein und er hat gemeint
seitdem er das macht, also damit du musst, er hat auch erzählt du musst auf jeden Fall
immer Schutzdinger, Zeugs und so anziehen, aber er hat gemeint seitdem er das macht,
er spürt seine Fingerkuppen nicht mehr an manchen Fingern, weil das wohl voller kleiner
Glassplitter ist, nach 20 Jahren, also nehmt's mit einer gewissen Portion Skepsis, ich weiß
jetzt nicht mehr wo das war oder ob der einfach nur gelabert hat, aber das muss wohl nicht
ganz so ohne sein, dicke Glasfaserkabel spleißen.
Gamepad Dankeschön für den Sub, Hogu, so sieht's aus, ich benutze auch nur noch die
Linux auf der Arbeit, schon seit 15 Jahren und privat auch zum großen Teil, aber mache
noch genug unter Windows, ich kann dir übrigens was empfehlen, wenn du gerne Konsole spielst,
mal Werbung machen für mein letztes Video, weil kein Mensch irgendwie mein letztes Video
gesehen hat, guck mal, 12k zu sonst was, das hat über 10.000 Views weniger als meine anderen
Videos in dem Zeitraum, also falls du dich für Konsolengaming interessierst und mal
schon drüber nachgedacht hast, eine Emulationskiste zu bauen, dann kann ich dir das Ding hier
empfehlen, ein UM690 für so 560 Euro, du kannst auch die deutlich deutlich billigere nehmen,
wenn du nur alles bis inklusive PS2 emulieren willst, dann hast du eine Kiste für alle
Systeme, sogar die Switch, sogar die Switch kannst du damit emulieren, Wii U, Switch,
du kannst theoretisch auch Xbox 360 und PS3 emulieren, aber die Performance vom PS3 Emulator
ist nicht so geil.
Xbox 360 gibt es jetzt ab der nächsten Batocera Version.
Ich hab im Hintergrund da ein Mario Kart Gameplay laufen, das ist upscaled auf 1440p mit zusätzlichem
Anti-Alasing und Widescreen Mod, also du kannst Mario Kart Double Dash Dot spielen mit Widescreen,
viel bessere Auflösung, Anti-Alas, Texturfilter und so, das ist halt mega nice.
Ne, nehmt keinen Raspberry Pi, Raspberry Pi ist zum Emulieren wirklich nicht gut geeignet.
Kauft ihr, kauft ihr, wenn du wirklich was haben willst, was alles, was das meiste macht,
kauft ihr 19 Euro ThinkLine auf Ebay oder auf Amazon, was übrig geblieben ist, die
machen meistens alles bis teilweise inklusive PS2.
Locker, locker, Alter, Leute, ihr könnt auf dem billigsten, billigen uralt Atomrechner
alles bis fast PS2 emulieren.
Natürlich nicht upscalen, ja, also ihr müsst ja nicht anfangen mit zusätzlichen Texturfiltern,
Anti-Alasing, Upscaling oder sonst was von irgendwas, ihr könnt wohl sagen, wenn das
eben auch genau läuft.
Ja, ok, ich hab den Chat durch, Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein bisschen noch Setgeservers
an.
So, also ich erklär euch noch mal kurz, um was es geht.
Jetzt ist der, jetzt der Stream hat sich ja auch gefüllt, wo hast du dein Minis von Amazon?
Angst vor Spoilern, wie, Spoiler beim Sommerfixen oder wie, ja gut tun, UM690, äh, ok, ok,
ok, what, warum, warum kostet die schlechtere Kiste mehr, ok, was auch immer, also man sieht
es hier nicht richtig, wahrscheinlich, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin, also der Preis hier
ist Blödsinn.
Du bekommst, du musst es mal aufmachen bei dir auf Amazon, Moment, hier steht es doch,
ja, ach Moment, hier gibt es das nicht, oh das ist ja weird champ, das ist ja weird champ,
also guck mal, du kannst hier 140 Euro sparen, das kostet nämlich nur noch 830, oder 840
kostet er nur noch, dann ist es wieder billiger, also du musst mal ein bisschen durchgucken,
ob du nicht einen noch billigen findest, ich weiß nicht warum sie nicht einfach billiger
machen anstatt hier 140 Euro Coupon anzubieten, ist bescheuert, aber gut, ja, ich hab den,
ich hab den bei Amazon gekauft, ich hab irgendwie um die 800 Euro bezahlt mit 32G RAM und was
ne, 1TB SSD, ne 512G, ja, glaube ich war es, welchen Emulator lässt du darauf laufen,
ich lasse darauf laufen, den da, wobei das kein Emulator ist, das ist eine Linux Distribution,
die für fast alle schon Emulatoren mitbringt, ist mein Linux, ja, paar Sachen stören mich
noch ein bisschen, dass zum Beispiel hier das nicht ganz mit der Farbe übereinstimmt
oder mein Rofi vielleicht nicht, aber im Großen und Ganzen bin ich fertig, ja, also ich hab
ein paar Tosera drauf, das bringt für nahezu alles Emulatoren mit, wenn du Switch emulieren
willst, dann musst du dir das zusätzlich installieren, das kann es von Haus aus nicht
und Xbox 360 kommt erst in der nächsten Batusera Version standardmäßig mit dabei.
Los, Prime Subs giften, dann geht das, so, also jetzt fangen wir mal an, EDV Forensik,
zwei Monate lang, ich bin für den Zapf, siehste, so, so geht es, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
wieso ist das so schwierig, ok, da muss ich jetzt noch wirklich was kurz zu sagen, also,
wieso ist das so schwierig, Konsolen wie PS3, PS4 zu emulieren, also, prinzipiell würde
ich sagen, ist das Emulieren einer PS4 rein von der Architektur her wahrscheinlich sogar
einfacher als das von der PS3, weil bei der PS4 musst du grundsätzliche Sachen eigentlich
nicht mehr emulieren, weil es ein x86 CPU ist, wie überall anders auch, das Problem
auf der PS4 dürfte, ich hab keine Ahnung von PS4 Emulation, aber ich rein mir das jetzt
einfach mal so zusammen, das Problem bei der PS4 dürfte wahrscheinlich weniger die CPU
Architektur sein, sondern die ganzen Customizations diese da gemacht haben, also sprich, was haben
die für Sachen da drin, die du aufrufen kannst, also du musst wahrscheinlich die ganzen Apis
irgendwie nachbauen, was die Games verwenden, weil ich meine, die PS4 ist zwar ein PC,
aber mit sehr viel Customization, also du wirst wahrscheinlich die Architektur eins
zu eins laufen lassen können auf deinem Rechner, aber du musst ganz viel machen, weil das ist
irgendwie eine Custom-Grafikkarte, Custom-Anbindung für Speicher, Custom hier, Custom da, du
musst wahrscheinlich sehr viel nachbauen in Software, die eigentlichen Instruktionen
dürften CPU-technisch nicht so sehr das Problem sein, also ich gehe davon aus, dass die meisten
PS4 Emulatoren wahrscheinlich gar keine Emulatoren in dem Sinn sind, sondern eher sowas wie
Wine, rate ich, ich habe keine Ahnung davon, aber klingt mir irgendwie logisch, ja, weil
der PS3 sieht schon mal wieder ganz anders aus, die PS3 ist die letzte Konsolengeneration
von Sony gewesen, die quasi eine eigene Architektur hatte und sie ist gleichermaßen die mit Abstand
komplexeste, die es je gegeben hat, von Konsolen mit eigener Architektur, deswegen ist die PS3
schwierig zu emulieren und es ist beide schwierig aktuell zu emulieren, aber aus komplett unterschiedlichen
Gründen, PS3 funktioniert wirklich schon ganz gut, habe ich gesehen, also auch bei Uncharted,
es hat noch ein paar Performance-Probleme, aber das lief, also ich denke, PS3 werden
wir nächsten Jahren durchaus gut funktionierende Emulatoren sehen, bis da wirklich alles so
gut läuft, wie auf älteren Plattformen wird es, keine Ahnung, wird es vielleicht nie sein
oder wird auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen dauern, aber es ist halt schwierig, es ist
echt nicht so easy, Xbox Classic wird auch emuliert, ja, Xbox Classic hat witzigerweise
ähnliche Probleme wie die PS4, die allererste Xbox war quasi ein PC mit Nvidia Grafikkarte
und Celeron CPU, damals glaube ich, Xbox, ja, Hardware, oah, mein Auge, Alter, ja, also
die hatten, genau, die hatten einen Celeron drinnen, sowas in der Richtung, das war irgendwie
ein Intel Celeron und eine Nvidia Grafikkarte, so, das ist also quasi ein PC, aber die haben
ein bisschen das ähnliche Problem wie die PS4, die haben halt sehr, sehr viel Customized
an der ganzen Sache, das heißt, die müssen das auch so wineähnlich machen und die ganzen
Xbox Apis nachbauen.
Es ist mittlerweile nicht extrem schwer an ROMs zu kommen, ja, du musst dir die ROMs
natürlich von deinen eigenen Modulen ziehen, alles andere wäre illegal, ja, gut, ok, jetzt
machen wir aber wirklich noch ein paar Übungen, also ich versuche euch das ganze nochmal zu
erklären um was es hier geht, nachdem sich jetzt der Stream schön gefüllt hat und alle
da sind, du hast ja erst kürzlich den C64 in Batus Serra emuliert, die Spiele haben
ewig geladen, weiß nicht ob, keine Ahnung, aber C64 ist ja quasi auf jedem Drucker möglich
heutzutage, ich glaube Drucker haben noch zu viel Rechenleistung um das zu vergleichen,
an der Mikrowelle könntest du wahrscheinlich rein von der Hardware, die Mikrowelle ist
auch noch zu stark, mein Klo, mein Klo könnte wahrscheinlich CPU technischen C64 wiedergeben,
wenn es einen VGA Ausgang hätte, ja vielleicht emuliert das ja die Ladezeiten korrekt, weil
man weiß ja nicht, vielleicht sind dort irgendwelche Takt, irgendwelche Dinge an CPU Takt gebunden
und es geht nicht anders, keine Ahnung, mein Klo hat leider keine Grafikausgabe, also um
was geht es bei der ganzen Geschichte, das ist eine Webseite, die ein richtiger Fivehead
gut gebaut hat und damals habe ich es gefunden über Hacker News und er hat sich gedacht,
es gibt so viele Übungsseiten für Security Sachen und für Softwareentwicklung, also
es gibt ja solche Sachen wie Advent of Code, irgendwelche Competitive Programming Challenges
oder irgendwelche Hacking CTFs und so was und er hat sich gedacht, ok warum bauen wir
nicht sowas mal für Linux Administration und ist jetzt hergegangen und hat, man sieht
hier, die letzte Challenge wurde tatsächlich erst vor zwei Tagen eingestellt und hat ein
paar Server auf AWS eingerichtet, die automatisch aufgebaut werden und diese Server haben alle
ein Problem, deswegen sind sie auch sad, deswegen sind sie traurig und du musst das Problem
fixen, innerhalb dieser Zeit, dann sind sie happy, also im Prinzip geht es darum die Aufgaben
zu lösen, dass der Server wieder funktioniert, innerhalb von der Zeit, so und damit du das
auch innerhalb von dieser Zeit machst, schaltet sich schlicht und ergreifend die VM nach
15 Minuten aus, wir brauchen noch was, Narrow Peoples Setge, wo gibt es das, kenne ich nicht,
Narrow Peoples Setge, finde ich noch nicht mal über Google das Emote, das ist der Gegenteil
von White Peoples Happy, das ist Narrow Peoples Setge, so ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal schnell
für alle, die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren, wie das so aussieht, wir machen mal
die allererste Challenge, das ist wirklich easy, alter das Emote sieht richtig dumm aus,
das sieht mal richtig dumm aus, Narrow Peoples Setge, das mache ich nicht rein, das sieht
zu dumm aus, das funktioniert folgendermaßen, man drückt hier auf Run und dann sieht man
die Aufgabe die man lösen muss, wie gesagt das haben wir schon gemacht, Aufgabe ist folgende,
in der Zeit legt ihr eine VM bei AWS an, also die Aufgabe ist folgende, wir machen jetzt
mal wieder für den Chat DeepL nach Deutsch, also ein Entwickler an einem Testprogramm
erstellt das kontinuierlich in eine Protokolldatei, warlog, betlog schreibt und die Festplatte
erfüllt, sie können dies zum Beispiel mit bla bla bla überprüfen, dieses Programm
wird nicht mehr benötigt, finden sie es und beenden sie es, also das ist die Einsteigeraufgabe
Nummer 1, also deswegen ist es auch nicht sonderlich kompliziert und man hat die Challenge
geschafft wenn die Protokolldatei in den letzten 6 Sekunden keine neuen Logs bekommen hat,
so Moment, bevor ich das aufmache, ich muss erstmal wieder dafür sorgen, dass ihr die
Protokolldatei nicht abgucken könnt, ich hoffe ich hab das jetzt richtig, ich mach
das mal ein bisschen größer, ja so ist gut, ok, alles klar, so und jetzt hat man hier
ein Login auf den Server, unten links unten links sieht man nichts, das macht nichts,
unten links macht nichts, es geht um die ID oben, das hier macht nichts, hätt ich letztes
mal auch gar nicht machen müssen, so, da kann man sich auf die Kiste einloggen und
wird festgestellt, ok, wir machen jetzt einfach mal hier das auf, oh, tail, ups und ks, ich
mags mal starten, tail, jetzt haben wir hier oben die Logdatei, da seht ihr irgendein
Programm, schreibt da rein, also was machen wir, wir gucken jetzt mit lsof, welches Programm
da drauf zugreift, stellen fest es ist badlog.py mit dieser pit und sagen dann kill 594, so,
Programm beendet und ihr seht hier oben wird nichts mehr in die Logdatei geschrieben, jetzt
warten wir 6 Sekunden, t-marks war nicht drauf, wirklich nicht, ja auf dem hier vielleicht,
die haben ja auch nicht alle das gleiche Image, so, jetzt warte ich 6 Sekunden, dann sag ich
check, ups, jetzt hab ich den clue angelegt, check my solution ist korrekt, also so funktioniert
das, man kriegt eine Aufgabe, die muss man lösen, dann sagt man hier, habe ichs richtig
gemacht und das war's und dann kann man zum nächsten gehen, jetzt schalten wir die Kiste
wieder aus, um dem Typ ein bisschen Geld zu sparen, so funktioniert das, da fügt regelmäßig
neue Szenarien hinzu und das letzte Mal sind wir gekommen bis hier, Oaxaca, aha das ist
eine Stadt in Mexiko, alles klar, wie rüber man das ausspricht, kein Plassen, Oaxaca,
da sind wir stehen geblieben, die vm hatte das Problem, dass in der Bash, das war schon
richtig fies, also denkt nicht, dass alles so einfach ist wie hier, ja, das hier war
richtig fies, da war in der Bash RC ein Fehler drin, oder was ist ein Fehler, ein Fehler
in Anführungsstrichen drin, der jedes Mal beim Einloggen eine Datei geöffnet hat, man
sollte jetzt gucken, welcher Prozess das öffnet, dabei war man das selber mit dem
Einloggen, so und wir sind stehen geblieben bei diesem, bei dieser Übung, es ist eine
mittelschwere Aufgabe, wir haben 20 Minuten Zeit und ja, ich übersetz das ganze mal, so
also was sollen wir machen, warum ist der Server traurig, es gibt eine Python WSGI Web-Anwendungsdatei,
macht sowas überhaupt jemand noch, ja, unter home-admin-wsgi.py, deren zweck ist es die
Zeichenkette Hello World zu liefern, die krasseste Anwendung aller Zeiten, also diese Datei wird
von einem Gunicorn Server bedient, ist das die Python Variante von Unicorn, Unicorn ist
ein Ruby Web-Server, von einem Gunicorn Server bedient, dem ein Nginx Server vorgeschaltet
ist, beides Server werden von Systemd verwaltet, der Ablauf einer HTTP Anfrage ist also wie
folgt Web-Client zu Nginx zu Gunicorn zu diesem komischen Python Programm, das
Ziel ist es den Local Host auf dem Standard-Port anzusprechen und an Hello World zurückzukommen
unter, ok also das heißt der Test ist folgendes, das kopieren wir uns jetzt schon mal raus,
jetzt probieren wir das mal aus, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ah jetzt hätte ich jetzt,
der Server muss ja noch aufgebaut werden, hätte ich jetzt warten können.
Einfach Python Web-Server starten und Hello World liefern, ja Python, das könnte man
natürlich auch machen, High IQ Play wäre das, Leute hat jemand von euch schon mal Gunicorn
verwendet, ich hab bis jetzt noch nicht mal von der Existenz dieses Web-Servers gewusst,
Gunicorn GitHub hat bis jetzt in einem Python Projekt wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend
wieder 8000 Sterne oder so, war ja klar alter, war klar, ja ok, scheint hochkomplex zu sein
gerade die VM zu erstellen, ok da sind wir fertig, ok also fangen wir mal an, wir haben
die Info, dass dieser Test erfolgreich sein soll und wir stellen fest, dass er nicht erfolgreich
ist, weil Port 80 Connection Refused, ok also gucken wir als erstes mal System CTL Status
Engine X, ob das Ding überhaupt läuft und wir sehen, ja gucke mal da, Engine X läuft
gar nicht, na super, wenn es startet nicht, wenn es startet einfach, das ist ja viel zu
einfach, aber das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht gewesen sein, ja es geht immer noch nicht,
also wir kriegen gerade Bad Gateway, das heißt im Endeffekt, dass der Engine X, der läuft
jetzt, sonst würden wir gar keine, sonst würden wir gar keine Response vom Web-Server
kriegen, aber wir kriegen eine Fehlermeldung von Engine X, Bad Gateway und das heißt in
der Regel, dass die Anwendung dahinter, auf die der Engine X weiter balancen will oder
proxen will, wie auch immer man es jetzt nennen mag, nicht richtig funktioniert, so also gucken
wir mal, Grep Gunicorn, ok also hier sehen wir, hier läuft das Ding, das ganze geht anscheinend,
ok die haben keinen lokalen Port, das ganze geht über ein Unix Socket, gucken wir mal
NetStats, das ist auch so stimmt, was ich mir überlegt habe, ja NetStats sagt wir haben
auf Port 80 in Engine X laufen, ansonsten nix, ok also das geht über den Unix Socket
hier und da kann ich weiter leiten, das heißt als nächstes gucken wir mal in die Engine
X Config, was da so steht, Engine X Conf, ach ne ich bin falsch, ich muss unter Sides
Enabled gucken, Sides Enabled und dann wahrscheinlich Default, Default, Include, Listen, das sieht
jetzt erstmal prinzipiell, also Serious Leute ich hab aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung ob das
so richtig ist, ich müsste jetzt Engine X Config gucken, aber es sieht jetzt erstmal
nicht auf den ersten Blick so total verkehrt aus mit Syntax Fehler oder so, so das heißt
als nächstes gucken wir mal in die Log Files vom Engine X, was da so steht, machen wir
nochmal ein Curl, ein T-Max drauf, ne natürlich nicht, ok wir spammen mal ein paar Zugriffe,
damit wir auch mal so ordentlich in der Log Datei sehen und sagen jetzt Tale auf Error
Punkt Log, ok Connect to Unix Run Gunicorn Socket Failed, no such file or directory,
du hast HTTP davor geschrieben in der Engine X, was, ich hab nirgends sowas davor geschrieben,
das war standardmäßig so, Ups, kann doch sein das es Protokoll, aber Leute ihr dürft
Backseaten so viel ihr wollt, aber ich werd mich da nicht sondern nicht dran orientieren
weil der Sinn ist ja dass ich das selber rauskriege, also ich könnt so tun, als macht ihr mit
aber ich werd trotzdem mir das nicht so genau angucken bis ich das durch hab, dann guck
ich mal aus der Chat geschrieben hab, ist das ist doch ok, ah Moment ne ne ne ne das stimmt
ich glaub das stimmt, ich glaube das ist ok, es könnte auch sein das es nur Unix Doppelpunkt
Slash ist, warte mal Moment Moment Moment Leute guck mal, ja Splixer das ist mir auch
gerade aufgefallen, jebaited, der hat uns wieder richtig jebaited der Kerl, ok also das
ist auf jeden Fall schonmal ein Problem dass da die falsche Socke drinne steht, ok das
war jetzt aber Zufall, ok so Zufall kann es nicht gewesen sein weil der Chat hat es exakt
zum gleichen Moment gesehen, ok also die die Datei ist falsch, also es muss Punkt Sock
sein, also gucken wir mal, nicht Status, restarten wir mal den Nginx, ah er läuft, alles klar
Kerl, funktioniert, ich krieg nicht Hello World zurück, ich krieg, ich krieg nix zurück,
ich hätte jetzt gedacht es geht jetzt einfach, ok gucken wir nochmal ins Log rein, ok es
gab kein Errorlog Eintrag mehr, ich verwende das normalerweise in der Kombi nicht, keine
Ahnung woran das liegt, ok wir machen mal einen weiteren Jebait Check, der hat uns nämlich
schon öfters mit, vielleicht ist die Python Anwendung kaputt, das kann auch sein, der
hat uns schon ein paar Mal Jebaited mit IP Tables Regeln, aber das sieht, das sieht alles
gut aus, ich sehe jetzt da also da springt mir jetzt nichts ins Auge wo ich sagen würde
das ist kaputt, wo liegt denn die Anwendung, hier ok die Anwendung liegt unter, gucken
wir da mal rein, Home, Home Admin, Na die sieht auch jetzt rechts, recht übersichtlich
jetzt, ooooh
Entwicklerteam für irgendwelche Sachen zusammen
Meistens wenn ich was baue dann alleine oder mit eins zwei leuten zusammen wenn es was ist was wir brauchen
Ich habe zum beispiel das letzte bisschen größere was ich gebaut habe war ein
maintenance tool für unsere server
Tatsächlich das erste was ich was ich in was ich muss die content length null sein das habe ich gar nicht gesehen
Ne die content length sollte nicht null sein dass es
ist auf jeden fall da ist auf jeden fall schon was verkehrt moment
ne wobei der der der sagt
Moment konnte chat ihr habt recht wir müssen das python ding fixen man
Content length null
Boah das hätte ich nicht gesehen ohne euch serious die das hätte ich nicht gesehen
Das das hätte ich wahrscheinlich jetzt übersehen
Das ist wahrscheinlich der fehler also um das jetzt noch mal kurz auszuführen also das letzte was ich für
internen tools gebaut habe war oder auch gleichsetzt das erste was ich auf der arbeit mal in go gemacht habe
ist
Also wo ich das mal wirklich benutzen konnte ist ein maintenance tool
Und zwar haben wir jetzt ein kleines go programm auf allen unseren linux server
Wenn du das ausführst haben wir übrigens auch im stream tatsächlich angefangen zu programmieren
Natürlich nicht mit irgendwie bezug zur firma
Du kannst auf jedem unserer linuxserver jetzt folgendes machen
Ne eigentlich als set set down time kannst du machen und wenn du das ausführst
Dann verbindet er sich automatisch zum alert manager und hinterlegt dort eine silence fürs monitoring von
Jetzt bis in 15 minuten
exakt für diesen ein hostname
warum habe ich das gebaut
Weil unser support öfters probleme damit hatte dass leute warten
Arbeiten gemacht haben beziehungsweise auch angekündigte wartungsarbeiten so war das ja gar nicht
aber
Dann vergessen haben
das zu silenzen und
Als monitoring amok gelaufen ist das heißt wenn jetzt irgendjemand wartungsarbeiten an einem server macht muss er bei uns nur noch set down time eingeben
Und dann 15 minuten zeit sein zeug zu beenden und es gibt keine unnötigen monitoring meldung ja solche tools bastel ich intern
Ich habe auch was was beispielsweise was
beispielsweise was spam
Aufräumt was spam freigibt das ist ein automatisierter browser
Oder wir haben wir haben so eine so eine proxy log analyse die jetzt deutlich schneller läuft
Ein kollege hatte das gebaut vor jahren in bash das lief sieben tage
Sieben tage und jetzt ratet mal
Wie schnell mein dotnet programm läuft für die loganalyse also der zählt ips und so was wie viele connections wohin so
Bisschen proxy log auswertung sieben tage in bash raten mal wie schnell mein dotnet programm mit der gleichen geschichte ist
Paar gigabyte gigabyte von logs zu durchsuchen
Also gar nicht so schlecht blixer gar nicht so schlecht
Ja ungefähr 45 minuten es ist es ist schon viel viele logs sind es schon ja
Aber sieben tage versus 45 minuten ist schon eine ganz schöne zeit ansparen ist
Dann haben wir dann haben wir letztens letztens habe ich tatsächlich was gar ich muss es jetzt mal fertig machen sonst ist die vm gleich gleich weg
Wie wie fix man das in python überhaupt ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal 500 ich habe keine ahnung ob das was bringt
Körl
Content längst null muss man muss man den engine x noch mal neu starten dafür dass es dann funktioniert
Ne
Ne das python ding muss ich neu starten oder
System ctl restart
Restart guni korn ach tatsächlich lull kackel
Ne
Im muss ich muss ich ok ich ok content längst 500 das passt
Das passt ok ich muss ich muss quasi gucken
Wie groß die datei ist
Ich muss ich muss gucken wie groß hello world ist also sprich
Wie groß ist das content längst wie viel zeichen sind das lass mal kurz zählen
Ja hier eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben neun zehn elf zwölf dreizehn
dreizehn zeichen
Ja 500 minus 407 und acht leute habt recht lull ja klar können einfacher sein
Hello world wir haben es geschafft leute server ist white pepo happy
Check my solution korrekt jetzt jetzt ist er glücklich
Was wollte ich was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen
Ja ich habe letztens tatsächlich was was ganz cooles gebaut ich glaube dass das auch noch eine weile auch wenn ich da weg bin
Wie gesagt bin er bin der ein dreißig dritten da weg
Und ich glaube dass das auch noch ein bisschen länger auch noch ein bisschen länger benutzt werden wird
beziehungsweise in zukunft tatsächlich war wirklich sehr sinnvoll werden könnte da und zwar ich habe ein check gebastelt der guckt
ob unsere mails die wir verschicken
Ankommen wir hatten mal das problem dass außendienstleute
Zu viel spam verschickt haben über das mail system bei uns
Und deswegen
Gmx beziehungsweise united internet gesagt hat
Wir rate limiten euch
Und danach gesagt haben wir blocken euch für einen tag und es hat bei uns keiner wirklich mitgekriegt weil wie kriegst du sowas mit
Gerade wenn du rate limitet bist wie kriegst du das kriegt der sinn ist ja eigentlich dass du es nicht so wirklich mitkriegst
so und
Was wir jetzt gebaut haben ist ein tool was per imap wir haben uns einfach
Drei vier fake accounts gemacht ein tool was per imap guckt ob e-mails ankommen im postfach
Alle zehn minuten wir haben gmx drinne web.de drinne
google mail drinne
Das wars
Ja ich glaube das wars und wir schicken uns einfach im c also das gleiche das gleiche programm schickt einfach im zehn minuten takt mails
und guckt dann einmal
nach eineinhalb stunden ob diese mails alle in der vorgegebenen zeit angekommen sind
und
Das ganze stellt es als prometoise exporter bereit damit man sind grafana uns monitorin integrieren kann
Das heißt sie können die können jetzt abfragen ok sind dann die mail angekommen
die wir verschickt haben uns
Wenn nicht gibt es einen alarm
Das kostet das hier ist kostenlos das mit wo man die übung machen kann
Ok also wir haben den diesen server auch gefixt
Next
E-mail server und selbstgekaufte domain
Was soll das bringen? Also bevor ich dir jetzt erkläre warum das nix bringt wird mich erst mal deinen gedankengang
interessieren inwieweit ein selbst gehorchster der mail server und selbstgekaufte domain dieses problem beheben würde
Es hat schon mal jemanden die metzen ich wusste zum damaligen zeitpunkt nicht mal was es ist
und da habe ich nachgeguckt ich habe es schon wieder vergessen was es ist
also nähe
und
schon wieder vergessen, was es ist. Also ne, hab ich nicht. Das wäre nicht das Problem.
Machen wir das? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Vielleicht, vielleicht, aber genau nicht alles.
Das ist eine sehr komplexe Frage. Da geh ich gleich drauf ein, nachdem mir Logi-Leib erklärt
hat, was ein Selbstgehörster, der E-Mail-Server und ein selbst gekaufte Domain da jetzt bringen
würden. Ich mach das jetzt wie bei meinen Azubis früher. Da musste man auch hartnäckig sein. Die
haben auch gerne mal Zeug erzählt. Ohnezu, gerade Herr Endpunkt war da wirklich so ein
Spezialkandidat für. Die haben auch gerne mal Zeug erzählt, besonders überzeugt, dass es so ist,
aber konnten es dann schlecht erklären, wie sie zu der Annahme gekommen sind, dass es so ist.
Das lag meistens daran, dass sie entweder die Problemstellung nicht verstanden haben
oder sich im Internet irgendwas rausgesucht haben. Okay, also, ich will dich nicht flamen. Ich will
dich nicht flamen. Also, ich erzähl dir nochmal die Problemstellung. Also, wir verschicken Mails,
beziehungsweise unser Außendienst verschickt Mails über unser System. Das heißt, wir haben ja quasi
schon ein eigenes Domain und einen eigenen E-Mail-Server, sonst würde das ja gar nicht funktionieren. Allerdings
schicken die Mails an andere private E-Mail-Accounts, also von Kunden zum Beispiel oder von anderen
Außendienstmitarbeitern und die sind nun mal bei gmx oder bei web.de oder bei gmail oder sowas.
Lass den Gmail-Witz bitte stecken, Leute, im Chat heute, ja? Der kommt nämlich immer, wenn ich Gmail
sage. Kommt die Leute wie das, haha, Gmail, lululul, der hat schon so einen Bart mittlerweile. So, das
heißt, wir müssen jetzt überprüfen, ob die Mails, die durch unser System gehen, zu Postfächern bei
gmx und web.de und Gmail, ob die auch wirklich ankommen. Da bringt eine eigene Domain und ein
eigener E-Mail-Server nichts, weil die wollen ja dahin, das Ziel ist ja korrekt. So, und jetzt ist
das Problem gewesen, dass manche im Außendienst wahrscheinlich zu viele alles Gute zum Geburtstag
Mail oder sowas rund geschickt haben oder ISOs verschickt, wie Leute, was die teilweise verschicken,
man. Wir haben E-Mail-Postfächer teilweise mit ISOs drinne und sowas. Das kriegt man immer dann
mit, wenn sie über ihrem Quota liegen, auf einmal die Leute, denkst du, was machen die da wieder?
Und dann stellt man fast, fuck, da liegen ISO-Files im E-Mail-Postfächer und sowas. E-Mails selbst
angucken darf man ja nicht. Und was heißt darf man nicht? Doch, darf man, darf man, aber nur mit
Einverständnis vorher. Deswegen ist E-Mail-Restore immer größer. Wurden E-Mails von GMX nicht
gebounced? Nein, GMX hat uns Raid Limited und ich glaube dann danach irgendwie für einen Tag
Hardcore Raid Limited, wo gar nichts mehr gemacht wurde. Die wurden nicht gebounced, man hat nichts
davon mitgekriegt, was ja irgendwo auch sinnvoll ist, wenn die Spammer eindämmen wollen. So,
und deswegen schickt das Tool alle 10 Minuten eine Mail, gmx, web.de, gmail und dann nach einer Stunde
guckt es, ob diese 10 E-Mails angekommen sind per IMAP. Das Ganze wird per Prometheus Exporter zur
Verfügung gestellt. Das ist die einzige Lösung, die mir dazu eingefallen ist zu dem Problem.
Zum Schluss werden die Raid Limited durch dein Tool, nee, guck mal, eine Mail alle 10 Minuten
ist wenig. Bis jetzt ist nichts passiert. Das finde ich eine ganz gute Lösung,
weil ihr bringt keine Bloglisten was zum nachgucken, ihr bringt auch keine Bounce-Mails
auswerten oder so. Übrigens wisst ihr eigentlich, wie das Problem gelöst wurde, das war auch witzig.
Das Problem wurde folgendermaßen gelöst. Unsere Leute, die für E-Mails zuständig sind,
wenden sich an den gmx-Support. Der gmx-Support reagiert nicht richtig drauf und schreiben
irgendwelche komischen Template-Texte zurück. Oder so nach dem Motto, wir machen da gar nichts
oder sonst was. Und dann auf einmal ging es dann ganz schnell. Auf einmal ging es dann ganz schnell,
dann hat dann irgendwie, der fragt mich nicht, Head of E-Mails Server von gmx oder so angerufen.
Wir können unsere Mail queue monitoren. Das machen wir auch. In dem Fall hat das aber nichts gebracht,
weil, warum hat das nichts gebracht? Ja, wahrscheinlich weil gmx die Mails angenommen hat,
aber dann irgendwie Rate limited hat. Das ist eine gute Frage, warum das nichts gebracht hat,
aber ich weiß, dass wir die Mail queue überwachen und das hat in dem Fall nicht gezogen. Vielleicht
habe ich auch nicht 100% kapiert, was eigentlich genau passiert ist. Das ist auch möglich. Ich
kümmere mich normalerweise nicht um die E-Mails, aber die Mail queue Überwachung hat nichts gebracht.
Also wir haben es nicht gemerkt, dass unsere Mails mit Verzögerung ankommen. Vielleicht haben
die uns auch Rate limited, vielleicht haben die auch angenommen und Rate limited und es war dann
irgendwie bei gmx in der queue einfach einen halben Tag oder so. Ich kann es dir wirklich
nicht genau sagen, keine Ahnung. Was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade erzählen, Leute? Ich habe zu
irgendwas angesetzt, bis das mit der Mail queue gekommen ist. Was wollte ich erzählen? Ach ja,
wie das der Head of E-Mail-Dings. Also erstmal war der gmx-Support total unhilfreich und auf
einmal ging es dann ganz schnell und jetzt weiß ich wieder, wisst ihr woran das lag? Das ist
wieder sowas, was nur im Business Enterprise Umfeld vorkommt. Unser, also unserem Abteilungsdirektor
ist dann eingefallen, dass der regelmäßig, ich glaube, ich glaube Golf, es könnte auch
Tennis gewesen sein, aber ich glaube Golf, dass der regelmäßig Golf spielen geht mit
irgendeinem Chef von 1&1 und dann hat der den Typ quasi auf seinem Handy angerufen,
ja, iKarl, wie geht's? Bei uns gehen die E-Mails nicht, hast du mal einen Ansprechpartner für uns
und der hat dann wohl den Head of E-Mail-Server von gmx angerufen und der hat dann unseren E-Mail-Typ
bei uns angerufen. Also das ging nur so schnell, weil unsere Abteilungstypen oder unsere IT-Chefs
irgendwie miteinander Golf spielen gehen. Geil, oder? Nur weil der 1&1 Manager mit unserem
Manager Golf spielen geht, ging das so schlecht. Was ist hier los? Wir machen heute Linux Server
glücklich. Wir sind bei Punkt, wir sind bei der zehnten Übung. Als nächstes kommt
ETCD SSL Certificate Troubles. Wir haben das 5 Minuten gemacht, das stimmt. Wir haben zwei
Stunden gelabert und eine viertel Stunde Server gemacht. Ja gut, hey, was willst du machen?
Aber man muss auch sagen, der Chat stellt heute wirklich gute Fragen, zu denen ich viel sagen kann,
das finde ich nice. Ich erzähle immer gerne was, wenn es um sowas geht, da habe ich überhaupt
keine Schmerzen mit. Also wenn ihr sowas wissen wollt, dann immer, immer, immer raus. Das ist
hier nämlich auch, deswegen habe ich mir das markiert, das ist eine sehr gute Frage und ich
glaube, das ist eine Frage, die stellen sich relativ viele, die daheim ein paar Linux Server betreiben,
also sprich, Robert, ich vergesse Roberto, nee, L-Roberto-Lolol, Roberto-Lo, L-Roberto-Lo, meine
Güte, ich habe es heute mit Namen. Also der fragt, wie viele Server hast du betreut, wie läuft
sowas ab? Also das muss ich jetzt in verschiedenen Schritten beantworten. Also zu Spitzenzeiten war
ich zuständig für über 4000 Linux-Systeme, natürlich ich nicht alleine, muss man dazu sagen,
also es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich mich den ganzen Tag um 4000 Systeme kümmern müssen,
zum Glücklicherweise ist die meisten Systeme, wenn die mal laufen, dann laufen die, da passiert
meistens nicht sonderlich viel, aber bei 4000 Systemen ist trotzdem öfters mal was, es sind
dann einfach so viele, das ist so wie bei Festplatten und Raids, wenn ihr große Festplatten habt in einem
Raid oder wenn ihr viele Festplatten im Raid habt oder viele Raids mit Festplatten, so eine einzelne
Festplatte geht eigentlich relativ selten kaputt oder hat relativ selten Fehler, aber wenn ihr
möglichst viel habt, dann geht trotzdem was kaputt, öfters, weil es eben so viele sind und das passiert
bei 4000 Linux-Kisten auch, da geht mal ein Netzteil kaputt, da geht irgendwie mal, also übrigens wenn
ich 4000 Server meine, meine ich nicht Hardware, wir hatten zwar nicht wenig Hardware, wir haben
immerhin zwei eigene Standorte in Frankfurt mit Rechenzentrum und Rechenzentrum, aber keine,
das ist ja nicht DCX 2.0, das ist jetzt schon ordentlich, aber jetzt nicht mega groß, ich rede
von 4000 Linux-Systemen, da sind auch VMs drin, da sind nicht alles Hardware, aber wie gesagt,
bei den Hardware-Kisten geht auch mal ein Raid kaputt oder ein Netzteil geht kaputt und bei VMs
kann natürlich auch mal die ein oder anderen Probleme auftreten, es wurde irgendeine Version
deployed und es wurde vergessen an irgendeine Abhängigkeit zu denken, irgendwas läuft voll
mit Logs und das hat keiner mitgekriegt und deswegen ist jetzt die Festplatte read-only,
gibt ja zig Varianten, zig Möglichkeiten, was da sein kann. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich war,
in der Spitzenzeit waren es 4000 Linux-Systeme, mittlerweile sind es in der Summe wahrscheinlich
auch gar nicht mal so viel weniger, aber es ist ein bisschen besser aufgeteilt, also einiges ist
tatsächlich nach Azure gewandelt und läuft dort in irgendwelchen App-Containern und sonst was,
da sind keine VMs und keine richtigen Server mehr, also das ist da schon ein bisschen weniger und
vieles musst du dich infrastrukturell auch nicht mehr drum kümmern, also mittlerweile sind es eine
ganze Ecke weniger, es sind keine 4000 mehr, sind vielleicht noch, wenn man vielleicht noch 3000,
vielleicht sogar mittlerweile noch ein bisschen weniger, aber so wird über Daumen gepeilt wie
gesagt 3000 Kisten oder so, sind es aktuell. Bei Azure habe ich den Eindruck, so eingeführt,
aber nicht so komplett zu Ende gedacht, den Eindruck habe ich öfters mal, oder was heißt
nicht so zu Ende gedacht, oftmals zu, zu feifett gedacht, auch diese, auch die ganze Überwachungsgeschichte
bei Azure, also die ganze, die, äh, ne, ne, nicht Analytic, wie heißt das, Workspaces, doch,
ich glaube Analytic Workspace hast du sogar, das ist alles eine coole Sache, aber du musst
das ja schon fast studiert haben, bis du dir mal die RAM-Auslastung von einer VM anzeigen,
Lock, Lock Workspaces, genau das meine ich, ähm, bis, wobei, ich bin nicht sicher, ob
es Lock Work, dort wurde dir beispielsweise auch RAM-Auslastung von VMs und so anzeigen
lassen kannst, mit, mit, mit dieser Microsoft Query, Query Language, das ist eigentlich
ein richtig nicees Tool, scheitert aber so irgendwie an der Implementierung, du musst
das erstmal komplett studiert haben, bis du gecheckt hast, wie du da so popelige Sachen
abfragst, wie RAM-Auslastung von einem Server, und dann geht's los, du willst wissen, wie
ist denn die RAM- und CPU-Auslastung von diesen fünf Systemen zeitgleich, und dann stellst
du fest, du willst es nicht für alles einzelne Graphen haben, du willst es überlagert haben,
und dann, es ist unnötig kompliziert, es ist, es ist cool, was du mitmachst, es ist
unnötig kompliziert.
So, also das war die erste Frage, wie gesagt, Spitzenzeiten bist du über, bisschen über
4000.
So, wie läuft sowas ab, wenn man so viele Server betreut, betreut, oder wenn man so
viel, ich, ich übersetz das mal, wie, wenn man, wenn man so viele Server hat, dass man
die gar nicht mehr alle einzeln betreuen kann.
Das ist ein Problem, vor dem sehr viele Unternehmen standen, bzw. vielleicht schon der ein oder
andere auch im Heimbereich stand, wenn er mehr als eine Handvoll Kisten hat, was ja
durchaus mit Raspberry Pis und ambitionierten Homelabs durchaus so sein kann, oder vielleicht
auch noch ein paar Kisten dazukommen mit irgendwelchen Clouds und paar VMs und so, aber viele Unternehmen
standen die letzten Jahrzehnte vor genau diesem Problem, also sprich, was macht man, wenn
die, wenn man so viele Kisten hat, dass man die eigentlich gar nicht mehr von Hand streicheln
kann jeden Tag und das hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis sich da so paar Lösungen etabliert haben
oder so ein paar coole Sachen etabliert haben.
Früher hat man da sehr viel von Hand gemacht, immer noch, man hat dann natürlich irgendwann
angefangen das so in eigene Skripte zu packen, du hast es dann versucht so ein bisschen zu
automatisieren, du hast dir dann zig, zig Bash Skripte zusammengebaut, du hattest damals
noch zu Monitoring so Sachen wie Nagios und davor noch NetSaint gab es, glaube ich, war
glaube ich der Vorgänger von Nagios und du hattest so ein bisschen Config Management
Tools, CF Engine war das damals, muss ich ehrlich sagen, Nagios hat immer noch einen
Platz in meinem Herz, ich mag Nagios, aber vieles davon war auch ein bisschen zu zu sperrig
im Handling und da hat sich dann mit der Zeit immer mehr Software und Tools etabliert für
genau solche Probleme, weil wie gesagt alle größeren Unternehmen, also alle Leute mit
ein bisschen größeren Umgebungen standen vor dem Problem, also es fing an zur Überwachung,
das ist ja übrigens das Wichtigste, so muss man ja auch dazu sagen, der normale Server,
wenn er da steht und funktioniert interessiert dich nicht, aber du willst ja möglichst schnell
mitkriegen, wenn der nicht mehr funktioniert, also musst du das irgendwie überwachen.
So und das ging dann wie gesagt, ging dann los mit CF Engine und mit Nagios und solchen
Geschichten und das hat sich dann immer weiter verbessert, weil du möchtest ja auch Server
irgendwann nicht mehr von Hand aufbauen, so nach dem Motto hier, ich habe jetzt einen
Web Server und ich habe noch einen Web Server und noch einen Web Server und irgendwann kommt
da 25 Web Server dabei und jeder Web Server sieht ein bisschen anders aus, weil es vielleicht
eine andere Admin aufgebaut hat oder weil einer was vergessen hat oder mit einer neueren
Version installiert und das ist alles Mist, sondern da haben sich immer mehr Tools darum
etabliert, eben diese Probleme zu lösen und mittlerweile sind wir angekommen bei solchen
Sachen wie zum Beispiel Ansible und Terraform oder Puppet oder Chef oder im Prinzip das,
was der Twincore geschrieben hat, genau, also Ansible ist aktuell eindeutig das angesagteste,
wobei man sagen muss, gerade in Unternehmen ist Puppet Code auch noch sehr verbreitet,
also bei uns ist zum Beispiel sehr viel Puppet noch, weil wir machen das ja auch schon seit
langer Zeit und damals gab es noch kein Ansible und das sind Tools, da definierst du, wie
ein Server aussehen soll, was da drauf sein soll und du machst das nicht mehr von Hand,
also du hast dann quasi eine Config Datei, grob gesagt, du hast eine Config Datei, in
der steht drin, ein Web Server besteht aus einem Engine X mit diesen und diesen Config
Dateien, mit diesen und diesen IP Tables Einträgen und sonst was und dann kannst du das immer
wieder neu anwenden, ohne dass du dich von Hand drauf einloggen musst und dort irgendwelche
Sachen installieren musst, was den Vorteil hat, die Server sind am Ende gleich aufgebaut,
haben den gleichen Versionsstand und du hast auch nichts vergessen. So und dann jetzt gibt
es neue, neuer Ding noch Tools wie Terraform oder Pulumi oder wie heißt das Shit von Azure
noch mal, Biceps, nee, nee Biceps war wieder was anderes oder bring ich es jetzt durch,
es gibt, es gibt so viele, so viele Tools da mittlerweile, es gibt zumindest auch von
Azure so ein eigenes Ding dafür, das kann sein, zumindest ist Terraform so, das ist
doch Biceps, ne, das ist doch richtig, das habe ich nämlich noch im Hinterkopf, da habe
ich, das waren glaube ich Jammel Files oder irgendwie sowas, da habe ich schon ein bisschen
was drin gebastelt und fand es jetzt nicht so dolle, so und ja da haben sich halt jede
Menge, jede Menge Tools in dieser Richtung etabliert, das heißt eine moderne, eine moderne
Infrastruktur administriert man mit auf der einen Seite eben so einem Provisioning System
oder nennen wir es mal einem, einem Infrastruktur Provisioning System und einem Config Management
System, sofern es notwendig ist. Also du hast sowas wie Terraform zum Beispiel, damit legst
du Server an bzw. wenn du Cloud Provider benutzt, legst du dort Ressourcen an, also du erstellst
zum Beispiel ein Netzwerk, du erstellst VMs, du erstellst Firewall Regeln, du legst DNS
Einträge an, du erstellst NAT IPs, du erstellst Eingangs Load Balancer IPs und solche Geschichten
und wenn das dann alles da ist, dann hast du ein Config Management System, zum Beispiel
sowas wie Ansible und das führst du dann auf den Servern aus bzw. wenn du es richtig
machst, pusht das schon gleich drauf oder pullen sich die Server die Config dann, wenn
sie das erste Mal laufen, kannst du ja nach dem Start einmal custom so ein Skript ausführen,
was dann Ansible anschmeißt und Ansible konfiguriert dann die Server so wie sie sein sollen, also
das Active Directory Login funktioniert, dass alle Zertifikate getrusted sind, dass alle
User angelegt sind, dass die Verzeichnisberechtigungen stimmen, dass alle Pakete drauf sind in dem
richtigen Stand, dass alle Abhängigkeiten da sind und sowas, das machst du dann mit
dem Config Management System, also in der Regel ist so ein Zusammenspiel aus so Infrastruktur,
nennen wir es mal Provisioning und Configurations Management und wenn man da sich ordentlich
drum kümmert, kann man auch relativ große Umgebung einheitlich versorgen, aktuell halten
und betreuen, der wichtigste Faktor, der da aber oftmals leider zu kurz kommt, ist aber
danach, wenn das System schon läuft, dass du mitbekommst, dass wenn es kaputt geht,
das ist eigentlich wirklich der entscheidende Faktor, du könntest sogar sagen, scheiß
drauf, ich baue alles von Hand auf, wenn es zeitlich und manpowertechnisch irgendwie
hin kriegst, wichtig ist, dass du mitbekommst, wenn was kaputt ist, also es bringt dir nichts,
wenn du das schönste Config Management hast und das schönste Provisioning System und alles
super krass skaliert werden kann nach Anfragen, nach User, nach Load Balance Erlass, was auch
immer, wenn du nicht mitbekommst, dass der Kram am Ende kaputt ist, also muss das irgendwie
überwachen, so, man weiß ja, ob ich das heute auf die Reihe krieg,
das stimmt voll,
keine Ahnung, ich habe keinen Plan von passen, also es hat gereicht, einen Timer zu programmieren,
ja, letztens, das war's, AWS, also ich muss ehrlich gestehen, mit AWS habe ich nicht
so viel gemacht, aber bei AWS finde ich die Benahmung teilweise noch wirrer, wie der Kram
da heißt, das haben wir auch, ja, das finde ich auch ganz gut, wir haben tatsächlich
auch noch ein eigenes, lokales RPM Repo für Custom Software, beziehungsweise RPMs, die
der Hersteller liefert regelmäßig, die es nicht public über irgendwelche Bezugsquellen
gibt, die schicken dann ohne Mist, die schicken dann per Mail-Anhang, ist kein Spaß, die schicken
dann per Mail-Anhang teilweise noch RPMs, früher haben die sogar noch CDs per Post geschickt,
aber gut, ich arbeite bei einer Bank, da malen die Mühlen halt langsam, aber viele uploaden
ihre RPMs mittlerweile auch, das sagt mir nichts, nee, nicht dass ich wüsste, was ist
der Unterschied zwischen einer Fachinformatik für Systeme, naja, das eine ist der Name
der Ausbildung und das andere ist eher was, was man in der Jobbeschreibung nachher sieht.
Ja, korrekt, so sieht es aus, ok, ah, jetzt, ich glaube jetzt weiß ich was du meinst, jetzt
weiß ich was du meinst, du meinst, wenn zum Beispiel dein Chef zu dir kommt und sagt,
eh, keine Ahnung, es muss jetzt sofort auf allen Systemen das Route-Passwort geändert
werden, so, das ist das was du unter Betreuen verstehst, oder, eh, da gibt es natürlich
verschiedene Möglichkeiten für, du kannst sowas auch über Ansible machen, du kannst
ja über Ansible auch einfach Kommandos ausführen, wichtig ist halt, dass du eine Übersicht über
deine Infrastruktur hast, brauchst du irgendwie einen Inventory, wo alle Kisten drin sind,
am besten auch halbwegs gescheit getaggt, dass du die Sachen auch selektiv ausführen
kannst, ja, also du kannst auch über Ansible einfach Kommandos ausführen, ja, du kannst
auch, du kannst auch über Ansible irgendwie Zeug-Auswertung machen über deine Linux-Server,
es gibt aber verschiedene Möglichkeiten, mal unabhängig jetzt von Ansible, für Auswertung
ist natürlich weiterhin wichtig, dass du die Systeme im Monitoring hast, vielleicht
dass du auch ein paar Metriken erfasst hast, dann kannst du nämlich so einfache Sachen
wie, warum war die CPU-Last heute Nacht so hoch, oder auf welchen Kisten war die CPU-Last
heute Nacht noch so hoch, relativ einfach beantworten, aber wenn du sag mal immer noch
so klassische Administrationstasks hast, also, vielleicht läuft ja wirklich die Logs voll
auf dem System, dann verbindest du dich nach wie vor auf das System per SSH und löschst
dort die Logs, also, das ist auch bei 4000 Servern nicht anders, also deswegen ist ja
auch wichtig, dass du Monitoring hast, dass du das mitkriegst, am besten bevor die Festplatte
voll ist, du loggst dich dann per SSH ein und löschst die Logs oder zippst die Logs
oder sowas, das ist dann der einfachste Fall, du kannst auch so viel Cluster SSH verwenden,
wenn es sag mal mal weniger als 30 Kisten sind, Cluster SSH ist eigentlich so ein uralt
Pearl-Tool, sieht so aus, Cluster SSH, ja, so sieht das aus, guck, du hast mehrere Fenster,
du bist auch parallel auf, du kannst auch T-Max verwenden und da Multiplexing einschalten
und sowas, kannst du ja, kannst du auch machen, aber ich persönlich mag Cluster SSH immer
noch ganz gern, da bekommst du dann ein Input Fenster und kannst damit auf mehreren Servern
gleichzeitig schreiben und sowas, ja, ansonsten, wenn dein Monitoring sagt, auf Server XY
ist was kaputt, dann loggst du dich nach wie vor auf Server XY ein und versuchst das zu
wichsen, na, das hat sich zu früher nicht geändert, du weißt heute vielleicht ein bisschen
besser über deine Systeme Bescheid, beziehungsweise du kannst doch irgendeinen Change-Log dir
angucken, wann da wie was dran passiert ist, zumindest Config-Management technisch, du
kommst dann vielleicht dahinter, warum es Probleme gibt, aber es kommt immer noch oft
genug vor, dass du dich per SSH auf eine Kiste einloggen musst und gucken, was ist kaputt
und dann da irgendwas beheben, ja, ja, wie man das mitbekommt, ja, das habe ich ja schon
beantwortet, ja, also die Übersicht behält man tatsächlich mit ordentlichem Server Monitoring
und natürlich in irgendeinem Inventory, wo da eine Kisten drinne erfasst sind, was sich
einfach anhört, das aber nicht ist, also bei den großen Umgebungen, da bist du mal
eine Woche im Urlaub und es gibt 15 neue Kisten, so übertrieben gesagt.
Beste Inventory Software, ich kann dir sagen, mit was wir das machen, aber ich würde nicht
sagen, dass sie wirklich so die beste ist, oder so, ich glaube der Twingo hat schon was
von Netbox geschrieben, das habe ich auch schon ein paar mal gelesen, das ist ja glaube
ich irgendwas, also gibt es auf GitHub, das hatte ich mir lokal auch schon mal installiert
zum angucken, war das nicht sogar was von Netflix oder so, von Google, war das nicht von irgendeinem
größeren GitHub, Netbox, war das nicht von irgendeinem größeren Anbieter gesponsort
sogar, ach was, Digital Ocean war es, Digital Ocean, genau, ja, sowas kann man nehmen, oder
aber man nimmt halt was, was integriert ist in so das jeweilige Provisioning System, also
man kriegt so ein Inventory, wenn man wirklich alles über, sagen wir mal so was wie Terraform
macht und so, kriegt man darüber auch ein Inventory raus, allerdings muss man sagen,
Systeme die mit Terraform aufgebaut wurden, die sind eigentlich nicht so sehr dafür gedacht,
dass man dort dann da Daily Administration Tasks macht, weil ja dann das Date so ein
bisschen out of sync kommt und ja das ist, das muss man sich alles genau überlegen was
man da so treibt, also ich kann dir sagen womit wir das machen, wir haben seit Jahren
schon, das ist ja nicht die geilste Software, aber die ist von der Funktion her durchaus
ok, wir haben dieses Ding, nicht Fireman Formen, das schaut dann so aus, das sind alle Hosts,
alle Deluxe Kisten die du hast registriert, also sprich wenn du was aufbaust, dann drückst
du da oben auf Create Host, also wenn du es von Hand aufbaust, ja wenn du es von Hand
hast, Create Host und dann kannst du auch direkt darüber VMs anlegen wenn du das willst, ja
das ist ja nicht die geilste Software, aber die ist ganz ok, ich hab den neuen Job noch
nicht angefangen, der neue Job ist am ersten vierten, ach das Ding meinst du, ist das Ding
was früher Spacewalk hieß, das kenn ich, ich wusste nicht das es jetzt Satellite heißt,
wenn das das jetzt was früher Spacewalk hieß, dann kenn ich das, ich fürchte auch, Leute
wir haben nur noch, ok wir haben noch 30 Minuten Zeit, ok, ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
ok, komm, komm, wir probieren es, wir machen es, ein Set Server machen wir noch, dass на
знаю, wo wir engineers
noch was sinnvolles fazer,
Ich habe letztens in einem Meeting die geilste Aussage gehört, da haben sie, das war auf
unserer Daily, nicht Daily, auf unserer Weekly Wartungs Ankündigungsrunde, da hat einer sinngemäß
gesagt, also so bla bla bla bla, ja nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Service in Azure, wir reden
hier von der On-Prem Lösung, die in Azure läuft. Da habe ich dann gedacht, was? Was möchtest du mir
sagen? Das ergibt für mich keinen Sinn. Ich habe es dann am Ende verstanden, was er meint und es hat
Strenge noch mal auch keinen Sinn ergeben, aber ich habe es dann verstanden, was er meint. AVX ist
das Tower, das Web Interface dafür, also das hieß früher hieß es mal Tower. Ach Tower ist die
Bezahlversion davon, da ist es doch das. Manchmal muss es schnell gehen, Cluster SSH ist nichts,
wo ich sagen würde, das brauche ich jetzt den ganzen Tag, aber manchmal muss es schnell gehen,
ja das kommt ja durchaus vor. Ich meine, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir mal den Extremfall wirklich,
dein Chef kommt rein und sagt hier, oder was weiß ich, IT Security ruft dich an und sagt,
sofort alle Eingangs, Load Balancer am Eingang ausschalten. Ja klar, wenn du ein fertiges
Ansible Inventory hast und darüber dann Shutdown absetzen kannst, schön und gut,
aber vielleicht willst du ja einfach nur den Dienst runterfahren und du hast das nicht direkt
im Kopf, dann lockst du dich ein, per Cluster SSH auf irgendwie acht Kisten, sagst HA Proxy,
es nimmt jetzt die L Stop, HA Proxy und dann ist gut, dann kannst du weiter gucken. Also das ist
nichts, was ich den ganzen Tag brauchen will, aber es ist schon sinnvoll. Ich muss demnächst
ein paar Schulungen machen zum Thema Geldwäsche und Insiderhandel, das muss ich von meinem neuen
Arbeitgeber ausmachen. Doch egal, dass ich sowas schon mal gemacht habe, das juckt keiner.
ARD hat mehr Viewer als du auf Twitch, wie fühlt sich das an? Mich würde es eher wundern,
wenn ARD nicht mehr Viewer hätte auf Twitch, ich wusste gar nicht, dass ARD überhaupt auf
Twitch ist. Was er damit sagen wollte, okay, also okay, das mit Set-Server wird heute glaube ich,
wird heute glaube ich doch nichts. Was er damit sagen wollte, ist folgendes, es ging ihm irgendwie
um Active Directory und er wollte klarstellen, er meint nicht das Azure Active Directory,
sondern er meint unser lokales Active Directory, wo jetzt anscheinend ein paar Domain Controller
von mittlerweile in Azure laufen. Aber er hat es maximal unglücklich ausgedrückt, sodass du
gedacht hast, was, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Ach, ARD ist gar nicht das erste
deutsche Fernsehen, das ist jemand anderes oder was? Ich habe gedacht, die ARD streamt jetzt auch
auf Twitch. Hey Max, mal eine Karrierefrage, wie sieht es mit Quereinsteigern aus beim Coden,
nenne es nicht Coden, nenne es Programmieren oder Software entwickeln. Coden ist so ein blödes
Wort dafür, das würde ich gar nicht angewöhnen. Ich kenne auch keinen Programmierer, der das mag.
Seriously Leute, ich weiß einige von euch sind Anwendungsentwickler, mögt ihr die Bezeichnung
Coden oder Coder oder sowas? Ich kenne keinen, der das mag. Ich habe beispielsweise Master
Medien Informatik, wir sind Broggers, genau. Ich habe beispielsweise Master Medien Informatik
studiert, bin dann aber seit etwas mehr als zwei Jahren ins E-Learning geraten und programmiere
dort leider nicht, möchte es nun aber wieder. Ich sehe dort aktuell aber eine gewisse Höhe
beeinträchtigt, da ich eine Weile nicht programmiere. Es ist ja die Frage, wie gut du es kannst.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ich lese jetzt ja daraus, du hast ja auch privat dich nicht, sondern nicht
mit der Sache beschäftigt. Es ist wahrscheinlich auch so fragwürdig, ob man direkt nach dem Studium
ready ist, einen Vollzeit-Software-Entwickler-Job zu machen oder ob es dann erstmal eine gewisse
Einarbeitung braucht. Also gut, Einarbeitung braucht es ja immer. Das kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Ich habe keine Medien Informatik, Informatik allgemein studiert. Ich weiß nicht, wie fit
man da für den Programmierer-Alltag ist. Man ist wahrscheinlich theoretisch ganz gut,
was irgendwelche Algorithmen angeht, aber was so die normale Software-Entwicklungspraxis
im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld angeht, ist man aber noch ziemlich unbeschriebenes Platt.
Also bevor du dich bewirbst, solltest du auf jeden Fall mal das ein oder andere private
Projekt machen. Außerdem bist du kein Quereinsteiger, wenn du Medien Informatik studiert hast. Also
solltest du auf jeden Fall, bevor du dich bewirbst, mal ein bisschen die Sachen auffrischen.
Gucken, ob das dir wirklich auch alles liegt. Kann ja immer noch sein, dass du denkst, dass
du Bock drauf hast, aber gar nicht wirklich Bock hast, wenn du es dann machen musst. Vielleicht
so ein paar kleinere private Projekte, vielleicht aus Bereichen, die dich auch interessieren.
Vielleicht weißt du ja noch gar nicht, welche Bereiche dich da groß angebrechen. Da kann
man auch wissen, wo du dich bewerben solltest und wo nicht. Am besten diese Projekte schön
ordentlich und direkt auf GitHub hauen, weil GitHub-Links bzw. GitHub-Profile sind in Bewerbungen
sehr beliebt. Das kam bei meiner Bewerbung beispielsweise auch gut an, dass ich GitHub-Profile
drinne hatte. Obwohl ich mich nicht als Software-Entwickler beworben habe. Wir haben erst noch mal 15
Stunden über Elektroautos geschwätzt. Ich habe natürlich den Fiat Champ angepriesen,
direkt im Vorstellungsgespräch. Einer hat erzählt, er hat auch ein Elektroauto. Da habe
ich gesagt, ja, kann er mal den Fiat Champ ausprobieren. Einer hat keinen Fiat, der hat
glaube ich einen Jeep. Irgendetwas Fettes und ich glaube, es ist ein Jeep. Aber gut,
so Leute haben eh viel zu viel Geld. Für den reicht ein SUV wahrscheinlich nicht. Der
hat wahrscheinlich ein Jeep Truck oder so. Ich glaube, ein Jeep hat er. Vielleicht habe
ich ihm gleich gesagt, kann er mal den Fiat Champ ausprobieren um sein Auto. Wobei gibt
es richtige Jeeps eigentlich als E? Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Also für mich ist so ein
Jeep so ein halber Truck quasi. Ach, gerne. Ach so, immer. Vielleicht hat er das einfach
nur erzählt, um das Gesprächsthema, um das Gespräch da drauf zu lenken. Habe ich den
Server aufgemacht schon? Nee, habe ich nicht. Zum Glück. Wobei. Okay, Leute, wir machen
das jetzt. 13 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit. Wir fixen jetzt ETCD SSL Certificate Troubles.
Auf geht's. Bam. Vorher scroll ich den Chat schnell durch. Warum wollte er denn nicht
mehr booten am BIOS Update? Ich habe ein Firmware Update auf allen meinen Ruckus Access Points
gemacht. Ging erstaunlich gut, ohne jegliche Probleme. Okay, Speedrun. Aha. Da ist bestimmt
das UEFI, die Einträge, was wo gebootet werden soll, durcheinander gekommen. Auf geht's.
Aber der Server ist immer noch nicht ready. Gut, haben wir noch nichts verpasst. Also was
ist denn überhaupt die Aufgabe? Okay, die Aufgabe ist folgende. Dieb, Dieb, Diebelfragen.
Also Beschreibung auf HTTPS Local House 2379 läuft ein ETCD Server. Der ETCD wird überhaupt
nicht weiterentwickelt, oder? Der den, das ist so ein Key Value Store, Distributed Key
Value Store Cluster, Geschiss für Cloud Native Leute. Der den Wert für den Schlüssel FU abfragt,
das heißt, ETC, ETCD, CTL, GET, FU oder CURL, Keys, FU? Okay, Test ist ETCD, CTL, GET, FU,
gibt bar zurück. Alles klar. Was ist mit den Fragen vor der Flughafen? Ich habe mitbekommen,
dass die Lufthansa IT Probleme hat. Und sie haben gesagt, der Hecht der Techniker arbeitet
zurzeit mit Hochdruck an der Lösung des Problems oder sowas. Also so eine 0815 Antwort. Okay,
Bäm. Es geht nicht. Wer hätte das gedacht? Certificate has expired. Das ist doof. Ich
habe keinen Plan von ETCD, man. Wir haben zwar den ETCD Cluster, aber außer aufgesetzt ab und zu
mal was abgefragt. Und mittlerweile ist das Ding auch abgeschaltet. Ich habe persönlich den
Abbauaufdruck auch gestellt. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, es gibt einen ETC. Es gibt
irgendwo eine Datei. Da steht drinnen. War das war das vielleicht sogar eine Variable? Ja,
ETCD, CTL, Endpoint. Na gut, Logelhaus. Ja, super. Okay, System CTL Status ETCD. Aha,
okay, okay, okay, nice. Warning. Create transport failed. OMG. So, dann führen wir mal den Kram
aus und gucken, was da passiert. Ich habe noch absolut keine Ahnung, woran das liegt. Minus K
habe ich auch dran gedacht. Probieren wir gleich aus. Minus K ist für alle die es nicht
ist. Wir müssen Zertifikatsfehler ignorieren. Response invalid. Endpoint is probably not
valid. ETC Cluster Endpoint. Wahrscheinlich ist es hier nicht gesetzt. Führen wir das
mal hier aus. ETCD. Misconfigured. Zertifikat has expired or is not valid. Is not yet valid.
Moment, was? Nee, das haben wir heute nicht. Gut, vielleicht haben sie das auch nur für
den Test eingestellt. Nee, das haben wir nicht für den Test eingestellt. Okay, also der Server
hat die falsche Uhrzeit beziehungsweise was heißt die falsche Uhrzeit? Der Server ist
auf der Uhrzeit, dass das Zertifikat nicht mehr gültig ist zu dem Zeitpunkt auf jeden
Fall. Die Sache ist nur die, dass am 30.01. das Zertifikat auch so ausgelaufen ist. Was
heißt die Übung funktioniert gar nicht, wenn man den Server auf die aktuelle Zeit stellt,
weil wir haben 15.02.2023 und ich glaube, da muss sein Beispiel updaten, weil wenn ich
den Server jetzt auf die aktuelle Zeit stelle, dann wird es nicht funktionieren. Wir stellen
den Server mal auf eine Zeit, wo es, also normalerweise hätte ich jetzt sowas hier gemacht. Nämlich
Abteil, nee, NTP Date oder sowas, was sich installiert ist. Aber bringt ja nichts, ich
nehme eh nichts ins Internet raus. Wir können einfach die Uhrzeit mal stellen und gucken,
was dann passiert. Aber vorher machen wir noch mal das Curl und das, was der Chat vorgeschlagen
hat, hätte ich jetzt auch gemacht. Minus K, Minus K ist Zertifikatsfehler ignorieren.
Guckt. Da, nee. Alter, da. Insecure. Selbstverständlich Minus Minus Insecure ist die Abkürzung Minus
K. Also das kommt vom K in Insecure. Okay, Minus K. Wir suchen mal den Mainpage, Slash,
Slash. Wir können dort kein neues Zertifikat ausstellen, gehe ich mal von aus, weil wir
haben ja keinen Zugriff auf irgendwas. Wir könnten wahrscheinlich auch ein neues Zertifikat
generieren. Insecure. Wir könnten eventuell auch ein neues Zertifikat generieren. Können
wir einfach die Uhrzeit einstellen. Not found. Okay, das ist ein weiterer Fehler. Das ist
nicht der Zertifikatsfehler. Not found. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht. Das ist ein EngineX,
der dahinter ist. Warum ist denn das ein EngineX? Ist das ein Chebat? Der Typ hat ein EngineX
laufen auf dem ETCD Port. Moment. System CTL stopp EngineX. Curl. Nee, Curl, Curl, Curl.
System CTL restart ETCD. Let's start. Jetzt läuft ETCD auf dem Port, okay. Ach, Moment,
nee, der hat den... Moment, Moment, was? Äh. Ey, ich hab'
mich raste aus. Wartet mal. Ist da irgendeine komische Firewall-Regel wieder dazwischen
ohne uns Chebaten will? Nee, oder? Drop? Docker? Nee, ich glaub', das ist alles okay, oder?
Sieht normal aus. Und wir haben nur noch 5 Minuten Zeit. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Nee,
die Firewall-Regeln sehen, würd' ich sagen, okay aus. Ich muss mal den wirklich doppelt
und dreifach gucken. Der Typ Chebatet einen mit Firewall-Regeln, wo's nur geht. Okay,
nee, passt. Hä? Äh, minus Curl. Aber das Connection Refuse ist schon mal sehr verdächtig.
Okay, aber ich mein, es funktioniert ja schon mit Curl nicht richtig, also. Also, es sind
zwei Sachen, die sind merkwürdig. Einmal? Moment. Wie sieht's denn mit 80 aus? Okay,
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Vielleicht brauchen wir den Engine X doch? Nee, das ist
irgendwas anderes. Wrong version number? What the fuck? Aber Leute, irgendwas ist da
schon mal shab. Irgendwas ist da schon mal shab. Wir gucken mal, wo das Zertifikat. Nee,
das Zertifikat kommt vom ETCD. Also System CTL, wir machen mal was anderes. System CTL,
Stop ETCD. Bäm, so. Net Set, gucken wir mal, ob das weg ist. Alles weg. Engine X, Start.
Was? Äh, ja. Der Engine X läuft auf 4-4- Moment, was? Hä? Der Typ hat doch eine IP-Tables-Regel
irgendwo. Ich sag's euch, der Typ hat irgendwo eine IP-Tables-Regel verstellt. Wie listet
man überhaupt alles mit IP-Tables auf, man? IP-Tables, wer macht denn schon IP-Tables?
List all. Kompl- äh, ja. So. Minus N, aber N ist nur Name Resolution, oder? Also das
ist auf jeden Fall schon äußerst verdächtig, dass ein Request an 2-3-7-9 auf 4-4-3 rauskommt.
Das ist, das ist hyper sus, ja. Zumal, dass auch hier wirklich nur noch vier, da muss
irgendwo ein Redirect sein. UFW? Hä, aber IP-Tables ist ja UFW unten drunter. Bin ich
blöd? Seh ich's nicht? Irgendwo muss, irgendwo muss das Redirected werden. Input, da fehlen
doch, da fehlen doch. Alter, wie lässt man sich mit IP-Tables denn alles, alles ähm,
anzeigen? Das muss doch irgendwie gehen. Ich mach zu wenig raw IP-Tables um da irgendwas
durch. Minus T-Nut? Ha, ha, ha, ich sag's doch, Leute. Gebaited hat er uns wieder. Alter,
das ist ja, das, das ist wirklich fies, ja. Da guckste doch normalerweise nicht, Huftmann.
So, jetzt wird die Frage, wie löscht man was? IP-Tables, minus D, minus T-Nut und dann
Rule-Number? Warte mal, das gingen doch irgendwie IP-Tables? IP-Tables? Oder irgendwie List-Rules
oder so? Ja, List-Rules? Ähm, nee, Number, Number oder so, Lists, Line-Number. Ja, Line-Number
will ich haben. Line-Numbers. So, eins. Okay, wie lösch ich diesen Shit jetzt aus IP-Tables,
Mann? IP-Tables, minus D? Kann ich einfach sagen, kann ich, kann ich einfach sagen, eins?
Oh, fuck, Mann. Das weiß ich doch aus dem Kopf nicht, wie das geht. Chain-Outputs. IP-Tables,
Delete-Outputs. Jaja, gut. Nee, Flash will ich nicht, auf gar keinen Fall. Da geht ja,
da geht der ganze andere Kram da drinnen steht nicht mehr. Also auf jeden Fall minus D. Aha,
okay. IP-Tables, minus D-Outputs. Ah, minus T-Nut. Ich hasse IP-Tables-Kommandozeile,
ja. Wie listet man, okay. Rules. Wie listet man Nummern auf? Reihenfolge ist wichtig.
Ah ja, okay, jetzt funktioniert's, nice. So, Curl, ich glaube, wir überziehen die Zeit
gleich. Okay, Connection Refused, das ist gut, das ist gut. So, Start, etcd, Curl, minus
K, aha, aha, aha, aha, okay. So, und jetzt müssen wir noch, jetzt müssen wir noch die
Uhrzeit, ich glaube, ich habe zu viel geschwätzt, die Zeit ist gleich vorbei. So, jetzt müssen
wir noch die Uhrzeit umstellen von dem Server. Date, Set, Time, Manually, weiß ich aus dem
Kopf auch nicht, minus S oder irgendwie sowas hier. Alles klar. Auf den 22. Ja, okay. Na,
fuck. Moment, was habe ich da gemacht? Okay, etcd, fuck, wohin? Date, minus S, wo müssen
wir hin? 23 ist, okay, super, super, okay. Okay, 01, 01, das müsste auch funktionieren.
Easy, gelöst, fertig, GG Eats. Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy,
easy, easy, easy, easy. So easy war das gar nicht. Das war ehrlich gesagt relativ kompliziert.
Aber die IP-Tables-Regel ist doch abfuck, man. Wer guckt denn darauf, ob in der NAT-Output
irgendwie redirect von den Ports ist, man? Wer guckt sich das an? Das hat doch mit der
Realität nichts zu tun. Okay, wir gucken uns mal die offizielle Lösung dazu an, was
er sagt. Okay, das haben wir auch gemacht. Also das haben wir auch gemacht. Wir haben
rausbekommen, dass die Uhrzeit falsch ist. Nur mit dem Unterschied, wir haben damit aufgehört
und nicht angefangen. Nächster Tipp. Not easy to see unless looking for it. Ja, das
ist mir auch aufgefallen. But there's an IP-Tables-Rule that redirects to CPE. Das habe ich auch gemerkt
dann. Deleting this rule will fix the remaining issue. Ach, man kann NAT löschen, gut. Wir
haben es anders gemacht, aber auch okay. Und jetzt? Ach, das war es jetzt oder wie? Ja,
gut, das ist ja im Prinzip alles, was wir gemacht haben. Die NAT-Regel gelöscht und
den Server auf die richtige Uhrzeit gestellt. Wirklich, es ist tatsächlich alles gewesen.
Wir haben es aber andersrum gemacht. Wir haben das zuerst gemacht und dann quasi das Fixen
mit der Zeit. GG. Das heißt, nächstes Mal sind wir dann bei HART angekommen. Wir haben
alle easy und medium Server durch. Jetzt kommen die harten Kisten. It's always DNS. Kann
man das sortieren nach release? Ah, das ist gut, dass man es nach release sortieren kann.
Weil da können wir immer mal wieder gucken, ob es was Neues gibt. Pogu. Easy, genau. Richtig
easy. Gab es noch irgendwelche Fragen dazu, Leute? Ich bin gleich weg. Nee, der NGIN-X
war reiner Chebathe. Der NGIN-X war kompletter Chebathe. Es wurde umgeleitet auf den NGIN-X
und hatte eigentlich nix damit zu tun. Und er hatte auch einen Invalid-Cert, oder? Ja,
muss er ja auch noch haben. Lädst du die Challenges auf YouTube hoch? Hm. Warum eigentlich
nicht? Warum eigentlich nicht? Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht das, was ich da der 0815
Call of Duty Fanboy angucken würde. Aber es ist mal was Cooles. Lass uns mal was kurz
gucken. Kali-Cali-Chan hat das gemacht. Kali-Chan. Aja-ja. Fuck, jetzt habe ich meinen zweiten
Count geleakt, Mann. Kali-Chan hat das gemacht, so so. Hat sonst noch niemand auf YouTube
gemacht? Ja, morgen machen wir das. Und im nächsten Stream machen wir Unix-Porn aus dem
Discord wieder. Und falls jemand von Twitch zuguckt, Unix-Porn, es geht nicht um Porn,
es geht um Desktop-Hintergründe und desktops und so Zeug. Please no Toss. Achso, du meinst,
ich soll die noch mal extra aufnehmen und erklären? Ich hätte jetzt den Cutter gefragt,
ob er uns nicht das Stream best of cutten kann. Ja, ich könnte das auch theoretisch
noch mal neu aufnehmen. Ich weiß jetzt ja, wie die gehen. Und achso, nochmal angucken
kannst du es ja auch hier im Watt. Aber vielleicht ist es vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt, wenn
ich das nochmal aufnehme und ihm erkläre, was Sache ist. Ja. Nur gut, Leute, wir sehen
uns im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.